There it goes.
Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to another stream.
Broadcast me motherfucker.
Gotcha.
One.
We only did one week.
We didn't fuck anything up and that was
yesterday.
Yesterday.
We completely had it together.
Joining me this week is my good pal.
The very funny Mr.
Bill,
Burr,
Bill Burr laser gentlemen.
What's up Joseph?
Do you might know bill from all sorts of
television,
standup comedy things,
the Chappelle show,
blah,
blah.
Well,
I was one of the funniest guys out
there.
I love the 80 strikes back.
That's on the IMD CMDB page.
I'll have a failed pilot for some reason
on my imdv page were 10.
It didn't even air and somebody will.
We'll start there
talking about anything we're sponsored
by the fleshlight is a fleshlight.
Have you ever seen one of these bill
burr
flesh colored flashlight.
Now this what it is,
Bill burrs.
You Fuck it?
That's the butthole versions.
Patenting Technologies.
Fingers frequent.
Okay.
You jerk off though,
right?
I mean I assume right constantly.
Now why wouldn't I?
They would one on the way up to your
house.
This is all about rubbing one out a
fucking tool to masturbate with its
instead of your hand.
It's a fake vagina.
This is the saying that you shouldn't,
you shouldn't,
you know,
I'm not against it,
but it's just odd.
You handing it to me the first minute.
He won't just try to see how you react.
Oh,
I hope you got a good read.
Yeah,
it's get a good gauge.
Now I'm into.
I'm into porn.
I liked the videos and that type of
thing,
but I got to admit like if that's just
those sex toys,
it's like very serial killer.
Like were you just sort of fucking,
uh,
a part of somebody?
There's nothing else there.
I know what you mean.
You went to the butcher and you're like,
yeah,
just give me a slice.
A crutch.
This isn't,
it doesn't have to lose pussy.
It looks exactly like a pussy.
The Pussy one does.
It really doesn't have to.
It just has to be a whole.
Maybe you'd feel doesn't look like a,
a that doesn't,
that doesn't look like a button.
Hold it up to the camera.
That doesn't look like a bubble.
I think it needs a little work.
If it was a girl with a butthole that's
got a problem because that sucker's not
air tight,
you know that there's a little hole in
there keeping after you ruined it last
night.
I've never fucked,
fucked the vagina one.
I have never fucked the next CD.
I have never fucked this.
You just hold something up that'll get
into Walmart.
They're the only ones left.
Fleshlight.com.
If you want to sell something,
go to fleshlight Dotcom and buy it.
But you know,
we were disturbed because uh,
we went to the website,
we could not find a black one.
They have only pink fake vaginas now.
You know what,
you could go both ways on that one that,
that,
that is either racist or white people
get offensive.
Can get offended.
Like how come you're slicing up white
women and turning that into little
plastic pillowy things for people to
fuck.
You know,
it should have like a swirl,
like a jet popping,
like there's
old putting or it's like vanilla and
chocolate.
That's not bad.
The Zebra one,
hear my fucking mouth one,
two and yeah,
that other ones.
So you can finally have like a fake
Banaji was fake mouse licking your
balls,
whatever that is.
The flesh,
flashlight,
whatever you called.
It isn't a kind of creepier than it
actually does.
Look like a vagina.
Look,
if it was green or something like that,
maybe it'd be easier to fuck.
Dude,
that doesn't load enough to think about
it.
Being a serial killer is sort of a thing
that really doesn't look like anything.
It doesn't.
It doesn't,
but the vagina one does.
It really does.
Fourth grade and made that you just as a
good father be like,
oh yeah,
I can see that.
Totally does you?
You have a lot of talent.
You encourage them.
We were saying yesterday that it's funny
that they sell the butthole version and
the vagina version and what if the
butthole version just so out,
shoulda vagina version.
They just canceled making them because
nobody wanted to fuck her vagina.
Like 10 percent extra for the vagina.
Joe,
next time you fuck.
I try taking it out like fish in the
bucket and it fucking it out of the
plastic thing that with your hand so
much better.
Really.
Brian has a tip,
but health.
He's like the Martha Stewart or fake the
tip.
You like review sex toys?
No,
I don't review sex toys.
Only technology shit,
but I should.
I should have reviewed it.
You should totally do a full it version
of a review.
When you fuck the flashlight,
I take the food blog to the next show
us.
Show us she fucking it.
But you don't want.
We don't have to see your dick or
anything,
but we should know that you really are
fucking like you're naked.
No,
not even.
Take a picture right after you're done
and we'll try to get the level of
satisfaction.
Just feel my face the whole time using
it,
but that's it.
Is there a fucking thing on this earth
that's more disgusting than another
dudes?
Loads.
If you think about it,
if you ever touched you in the guy
pissing on you or shooting a load on
you,
no brainer longer and you have a wash
cloth right there and a stand up shower,
it's over really quickly.
That might be better.
Just a pool.
You just might be better when he's
writing quicker.
It's just like get it done,
wipe it off.
You're not like sitting there for two
minutes getting pissed off.
See what you're saying.
You get a laugh at the guy's face and
he's like,
I see what you're saying,
but to me it's a dude just shot a load
on me and I can't deal with it.
I can deal with the dude pissing on me.
That's an act of aggression.
A guy shooting a load on me.
He's like,
that guy basically just fucked me.
You know what I'm saying?
It just snapped from below.
You know?
It's just,
maybe it's just an accident.
He's marking me.
So an accident is how you usually market
animals usually use Peter Marks.
That's okay.
That's all.
Like I said,
that's an act of aggression and act of
aggression.
Urinating on me would not offend me
nearly as much as dropping a load on me.
That's just me though.
Honestly.
Things that I don't really think of.
What if it feels a long beard?
You know?
That's what I'm saying.
Asparagus,
pis,
four hours sitting in Yankee stadium,
drinking beer in the hot sun.
You're not.
You're not a sports fan
at all.
The only sport I was good at besides a
mixed martial arts and boxing is pool.
I watched professional pool,
which is completely.
I actually am watching the NBA finals
and I have to have the game on mute
because I'm convinced the announcers
hate my team and I.
It just.
It gets insane.
Do people get so fucking mad if they
feel like someone's doing bias
commentary?
I get so much shit from dudes who are
angry at me because I called the fight.
As I see it,
I try to be as objective as possible and
have like no one's my favorite.
I don't want anybody in particular when
I just want it to happen.
I have a bunch of guys that I love
watching when they fight because they're
good,
but I don't,
I try to never like root for somebody so
I do my best to stay objective,
but I
cold like a fucking see it,
some tooth kid crazy just because
they're so emotionally invested like me
with the Celtics.
I want them to win and like,
you know,
like I haven't gotten invited to hey,
come on down and watch,
watch game seven.
It's like I can't,
I can't fucking deal with all these.
I'm going to sit there by myself and I
have to watch it on mute.
I can't be around a bunch of other
people because there's going to be
people there who don't give a fuck or
they or they're going to be rooting for
another team and I will literally have
rage.
No,
I've really been examining it,
like what's silly?
It is silly.
I heard somebody told me that I think
Jay Leno said was I wasn't into sports
and he was just like,
wait,
why do I care if the peanuts beat the
Kangaroos and you know,
something like that.
And it just really sort of was like,
yeah,
why do I give a shit?
It's a trick.
People think that that the NBA finals
are rigged.
Like the Kardashians going on tmz saying
the whole thing is rigged is going on.
Kim Kardashians,
Robert Kardashian.
Robert Carnegie I think is the brother
of Kim and he's like going on saying
like,
you know,
the source that family,
one of the guys.
And so they got to reexamine the Warren
Commission next,
take another peek at the Zapruder film.
Come on.
Really the thing.
So the conditions looked into the moon
landing.
Doesn't somebody off that in the
Kardashians?
Married to an NBA player though.
There were.
Yeah,
that is true.
And the NBA also had a ref that got
busted with mob ties.
And I love how they acted.
Like he was the only one I was just
like,
you wouldn't notice that if you will.
Refereeing with them is 10 everybody up.
You know,
like if,
if he bet the under and everybody's like
falling out.
And I mean I know that's an
exaggeration.
Every one of the easiest
games to fix,
you know,
they had a problem with that with
professional pool,
with professional pool.
The only one time that a sports book
ever put a line on the event,
I forget what casino was in it,
it was at,
but it was in vegas and it was a big
tournament.
These guys are grinding.
They're out there,
you know,
professional pool player,
don't make much money,
you know,
even the best in the world.
So they,
uh,
there was an underdog.
This Guy Mike Lebron,
he hadn't won a big tournament like that
in a long time.
So they all got together and said,
Hey Mike,
Guess what,
you're one of the tournament,
we're going to fucking bet on you.
And they all threw in and everybody
dumped and they all,
they all dumped.
Mike.
Lebron won.
They cleaned up and the bookies never
put a line on pool again.
And they,
uh,
and
they,
they obviously figured it out.
Oh fucking everybody knew their driving
balls into the rail.
They're fucking supposed to get out ball
in hand.
They don't get out.
They scratch,
you know,
there was a bunch of shots were digital.
They will obviously bad,
well you know,
they do their best,
but these guys a high level pros don't
miss very often,
you know,
so they can fuck up and take a bad path
on purpose and a path that gives them a
high percentage of getting stuck behind
balls or something like that.
So they make errors on purpose and you
look at it and you're like,
why the fuck would that guy play that
like that?
Like this guy's a top of the food chain
world champion,
a snooker player got busted recently for
a taking a 300,
three,
300,000
euro bribe who's taken a bribe to a to
dump a bunch of matches and this guy was
like one of the very best in the world.
He's like a top line and snooker players
make big bank.
But apparently it's accountable.
What was his vice money?
Took it.
I just want the money.
You know,
he,
he said that they've done it before and
you know,
they got this guy on hidden camera and
shit.
It was pretty,
pretty devastating for the whole sneaker
community because he's like one of their
starburst,
but all eight people who are in the
community over there,
Bro,
you don't understand and giant snickers,
this crazy game.
It's like pool,
but it's played on a giant table at 12
by six and the pockets are really small
and the balls are really small and
they're colored and I don't know the
exact with mushrooms on the table.
It's not from the 70 percent of that
bumper pool or something like that.
I do remember bumper pull.
That shit was ridiculous.
They had like little mushroom trees or
something in the middle.
Little rubber ones to bounce it off it
because you didn't have space for a real
table,
so you get one of these goofy fucking
things was only 10.
You had to make it more difficult.
That's right,
yeah.
That was the seventies.
Everybody put some sort of reference to
drugs right on the table.
Pool has always had a problem with
people gambling dumping money.
That's like a common thing amongst,
amongst guys who bet like guys will back
pool players and the pool players were
dumping and cut up the money because
they know where they're going to win,
you know,
so that whole world,
the world of gambling,
when you get gambling involved with
anything and there's a lot of gambling
on pro basketball,
I would just assume it's rigged,
wouldn't you?
Yeah,
I mean,
you know,
I would think uh,
well I think the players make too much
money and so it's very hard like that.
And the way,
the way to definitely do it is some sort
of authority figure on the court,
like know referee and umpire or
something like that.
Given band halls.
I went to the game when a Kevin Garnett
hurt his knee against Utah,
which I'm sure you still have on
videotape essentially talking about poop
fan.
I don't even know those humans.
The referees were literally dictating
the pace of the game and it made like,
no,
I'm trying to equate it to what you do.
Be like a guy had no stand up and all of
a sudden he was great at stand up and
then five seconds later again,
oh yeah,
he doesn't have any.
It would,
it wouldn't make,
wouldn't be.
It's not consistent.
They will call and everything.
Everything,
everything.
And then you could just see them loosen
up the reins.
Then a guy would like literally take a
dude's head off and they just had no
blood no foul.
And then all of a sudden it was like,
did these guys bet as us.
It was almost like they bet like a
specific.
I don't know what it was,
but it was one of the weirdest called
Games
hasn't been busted for that though,
right?
Referees have been busted for doing
things.
Well,
they had,
they had that referee and uh,
I'm sure if,
if other ones got busted,
maybe they kept it quiet.
I have no idea as usual,
I have like one story and then EPA comes
law,
spread it out over every sport to start
pontificating,
more interested in conspiracy theorists
that I know because Bill Burr,
you'll start talking to him about it and
then five minutes and he'll.
He'll admit that he doesn't know what
the fuck he's talking about.
He saw a youtube video like,
what's this?
What's up with this gps?
I'm one of the people.
He doesn't use GPS.
I called him to give him directions.
I go,
you got gps thinking,
I'm just going to give him my address.
Nah,
I got a Thomas Guide,
fucking Thomas Guide like a goddamn
pioneer and like a pencil and eraser and
you're like putting compass like
directions on.
So you guys are acting like I'm churning
butter.
You guys both had one like fucking five
years ago.
Didn't show.
Yeah.
Well I did.
I get here.
I was on the issue
early,
early on with the GPS.
I had the first gps was a CD based GPS.
It was cd rom base,
so it only.
I only had a map of Los Angeles.
I've never even used those books.
I think I've just always used like
mapquest and stuff and maybe before that
my mom would like write down the
directions on like a Napkin,
but when I first moved here I had it
written down on an envelope,
get here.
There was no problems.
It's very easy when I first moved to La,
but I haven't had one a long time for
la.
That just seems impossible.
It is impossible.
There's so many.
You don't want to think,
don't use your brand.
Let the computer do a British woman
telling me what to do.
GPS,
you think the GPS is possibly dangerous?
I think it's a waste of money.
Then also one of my many non researched
opinions is I just don't like that,
that the fact that there's some sort of.
I Dunno what they beam a signal up to a
satellite.
It Burns back down through the
atmosphere and into my fucking car and
then somebody talking to me.
Actually,
I think it doesn't mean anything out.
I think it just is like a receipt like a
at you and it picks up what it's being
beamed at.
You as the time of that say,
yeah,
I don't want to.
I don't want stuff always beamed at me.
No,
you're getting it no matter what you're
getting right now you're getting into
see that if you receive it,
there's a beam coming at you.
Okay.
If there's something to receive it,
like a box,
like some sort of gps box car,
but all that's doing is receiving
something that's already there.
If your brand is going to be affected by
it,
it's getting effected by what's already
there.
No matter of the box.
You guys don't.
I,
I have led.
I've led on the inside of my thing.
You guys.
I'm going to die earlier because you
guys don't want to fucking use a Thomas
Guide.
Why would you think the GPS would be
dangerous though?
It's like the radio being dangerous or
there's Wifi.
We're doing this word broadcast in the
shelters.
Big
bottle.
You're drinking now.
It's more dangerous.
It is.
If you leave in classic Bar Room Point,
right?
They're plastic bottle is more danger.
Really.
Did you just got done doing research on
that then?
Yeah,
yeah,
it is.
Because actually,
like he said,
if you keep it in your car and heat up,
being heated up in a warehouse,
hopefully done but,
but they say that if you leave one of
your car and it gets really hot out,
it actually releases chemicals that
especially for men are not good for you
if you have.
Even if it's just in here,
just the fact that it's in a plastic
insert,
the chemicals are in the plastic.
Well now you're on my page.
I like how you're concerned about this.
That's what I'm saying.
You're not concerned about anything and
don't agree with that dude.
You're gonna fucking die.
It always ends up going to that.
By the way,
he just quit cigarettes like a month
ago.
So.
Oh,
there you go.
Uh,
a buddy of mine,
I had a buddy of mine was giving me shit
when I went.
I was about ready to head out.
A friend of mine was a long story.
I won't name names what the fuck I was
doing.
I was doing something.
We were going to go celebrate.
We're going to go get shit faced.
So this guy is married.
He has a kid,
so then he and he used to be a fuck up,
so I'm not married,
I don't have any kids,
and he sends me.
That sends me a text.
He was like,
you know,
dude,
it's pretty funny.
You know how like how,
how things turned out.
He's like,
I'm married and I have a kid now and a
responsibility and you're still out
partying and it's just like,
it's just one of those fucking people
just because you have a kid,
they think that automatically makes you
responsible.
You're still a fuck up.
You just have.
You're just passing it on now.
Well,
what's really funny is the nobility that
they attach to it,
and this is coming from someone who has
two children,
but I used to get so annoyed when I
would talk to people who had kids and
they would compare their life to my life
there,
but like,
well look at you.
You know,
you're just a single guy just running
around being the same.
But what the fuck do we have to make
people?
Is there a shortage of fucking human
beings?
There's 6 billion of us.
All right.
There's plenty of people,
you're not more noble because you're
raising a person.
I commend you for it.
I hope you enjoy it.
I hope you,
you know,
you really commit to it and you raise a
good person that doesn't turn out to be
a fucking psycho,
but it doesn't make you a more noble
person because you have a child.
Yet,
some of them think that they're more
just are doing the right thing.
They're not being silly with their life
like it's so slow.
Guy Really wanted to go out and get
wasted and he was jealous that I can
continue to live my sad,
lonely life sticking in your face.
It's funny,
single person so that I.
But he's a good shit though because I
called him up the next day.
I'm like,
dude,
you fucking failed a drug test like six
months ago and you took a header up,
your front steps,
walking your dog down the street and you
had a red mark looking like fucking
Jimmy Snooker and you're giving me shit.
Jimmy's.
He comes with a Jimmy slicker reference.
The superfly.
Remember that he would get on the top
row and all that scar tissue.
Love you,
Joe.
He did have that scar tissue.
That's what the old school guys would
cut their own forehead to bleed.
Oh yeah.
You know,
he's,
he's a,
he's to the rock.
The Rock is somehow related to superfly
snuck,
I think.
I think that was his uncle.
You really,
if you could send me name me a cooler
uncle.
The Jews.
Yeah.
Especially if you turn out to be a
wrestler herself.
He was,
um,
Jimmy superfly snuck.
It was my favorite when I was in high
school.
He was my number one.
Bob backlund was pretty good because he
had a real wrestling stance.
I appreciated that.
He went in there and looked like he
really knew how to wrestle.
He would arm drag dudes and shit.
You know,
like a lot of the characters.
It's almost like a joke writer hate and
a performer,
you know,
he's in there doing like the was a real
wrestler.
You know,
what really sucks about wrestlers
wrestling,
one of the toughest sports in the world,
but there's no professional avenue for
it.
They tried it,
they tried to professional wrestling
league a few years back,
but nobody wanted to watch it.
It just,
it hasn't caught on when things haven't
caught on.
It's very hard to get them to catch on
unless it's something fucking crazy.
Like mixed martial arts.
Mixed martial arts is so crazy and so
primal.
The ones that started getting on TV,
everybody's like,
Whoa,
Holy Shit.
You know,
it just gets everybody in.
You're not going to get that from
wrestling.
But wrestling is easily more exciting
than a lot of sports that are already on
TV,
including,
you know,
soccer soccer's not as exciting as
wrestling to me.
I would way rather watch like really
good.
Well actually I can defend soccer.
Not American American soccer is like if
la plays like DC,
the Columbus crew again,
it's horrible.
It's horrible.
But international level soccer is pretty
good.
Yeah,
because now you're dealing with like the
shit talk and goes to a whole nother
level.
You're talking,
there's wars one in lost between the two
teams.
There's Holocaust genocide,
that's true and fundamental and they're
singing songs,
you know,
they go nuts.
They got the Elton John Scarves on would
you hit what's going on in there in
Africa?
There's a,
I forget what country it is in Africa,
but two people have been killed in a
bunch of,
been arrested for watching the World Cup
because it's like super extreme Muslim
village that has a very extreme
interpretation of the Koran and
apparently the Koran does not allow
gambling,
does not allow any sort of games and
does not allow dancing and any of those
things they'll lock you up for.
So this is considered basically no gain,
no happiness.
So they go and go door to door in
arresting people for watching the World
Cup.
Brian,
did you google that real quick?
Tell me what the fuck that is,
by the way,
how's that coffee taste?
It's great.
It's coming out of an animals,
but I'm loving that.
Really?
This is really good.
Isn't it smooth?
There's a coffee called Kopi Luwak and
it comes from the butthole of a thing
called a palm civet.
This animal that eats coffee,
beans and shits amount and they go
through the Gi tract,
the digestive track,
and they pull these,
uh,
these little beans out of his shit,
cleaned them up and sell them and they
see they make coffee.
Adam in the coffee super smooth because
get an insect the and no,
it's like a cat,
like a civic notice of it is,
is this big?
Fucking not bad.
It's a little bit yet.
This is bullshit.
No,
no,
it's true.
It's totally true.
Called Kopi Luwak.
Luw Ak.
It's not a cat.
Cat's a civic,
but it looks like a cat.
You know,
it's got a long tail.
It's like this weird animal that eats
coffee beans.
So it eats the beans,
shits amount and then somehow or
another,
I guess there were thought the beans
were worth too much money.
Let these animals eat and like fuck
that.
Let's not let them go to waste.
Like somebody must be desperate when
they first tried it,
but now it's worth like a lot of money.
I probably wouldn't have tried it and
let's discuss them with them.
What had been this Coffee Cup.
But then it has,
it has it added a new flavor,
changes the,
it makes it more mellow.
It makes it taste better.
It really does.
It's good.
Not that good.
I like my favorite coffees from Hawaii,
but uh,
I'm stuck it in his armpit.
Did you find the story?
Yeah.
Said Somalians are going underground or
watched band soccer.
Is that what you're talking about?
There was a bunch of arrest to because
of Somalia is fucking buck wild man.
You know,
that people's postcard of Somalia,
those guys that are just jacking people
every day out there.
I know that we remember those guys.
Do you know what they're doing?
You know the whole thing about Somali
pirates,
you know,
they're,
they're high on a drug.
They take this thing called cat.
It's like a plant that they,
uh,
they chew like the leaves of this plant
and it's a narcotic.
It's like,
like crystal meth for like the boy
soldiers over there.
I don't know what's the boy soldiers.
That's like when you're eight years old,
but you're a soldier.
Oh,
well yeah.
I mean there's the war out over there.
It's incredible.
You see dudes with like hyenas on chains
and they're carrying around fucking
rocket launchers to on the streets.
I mean someone like Liberia,
like some of the videos about you ever
seen the vice guide series online?
These guys that go to the,
some of the craziest fucking places in
the world and you see someone the
nuttiest shit,
like they went to the Arctic circle with
this guy who lives up there in a fucking
cabin in the arctic circle and then Hans
Caribou all day.
That's all he does is he hunts and eats
and and eats sort of happens when you
tap out.
This guy's been there for 30 years
though.
It's really fascinating.
But anyway,
they went to North Korea and they also
went to Liberia in Liberia is fucking
crazy.
They are the first of all,
there's been.
There's been war in Liberia forever.
Liberia was basically founded the,
from what I understand is they had
American slaves.
They let go and they sent them back to
Africa and they formed Liberia and the
UN was there until really recently,
like 10,
20 years ago or something like that.
And now they're gone.
And the place is just chaos,
it's just war and cannibalism is running
rampant.
They're eating each other left and
right.
They sell like human food on the corner
like human meat and people don't know it
and they buy it and guys turn people in
and there's this one guy,
his name was general but naked because
he would go to war and he would get
buttoned naked and he believed that he
could not be killed because he would eat
the blood and flesh of an innocent child
of the enemy.
So they would go to the enemy's camp,
they would steal a child,
killed the child and eat,
eat,
eat a piece of his fucking heart because
they felt like they wouldn't be able to
die in combat.
This is a god that's alive right now.
It sounds like a plan.
No.
Realize how fucking crazy the world can
be until you watch what's going on in
Africa.
Uh,
yeah.
I mean,
I dunno,
I,
I take a lot of comfort in knowing that
I can only die once.
How do you think?
What did I don't think like you,
you work out too much.
You wouldn't be worth.
He is the job like a flank steak,
you know,
just some tough piece of meat.
You don't want to.
You want be more ideas will be
delicious.
Oh,
you'd be like veal and he could sell
them for days.
If you think about the way Africa is
right now with a lot of countries like
Liberia and Somalia,
it really is like the apocalypse.
Like if that was going on right here,
if that was over here,
if we,
if we were in,
in,
you know,
in fucking North Hollywood,
there was gangs that were eating each
other and fucking shooting at each other
and walking down the street with hyenas.
We would go,
okay,
the end is here.
This is the end.
Yeah,
but you know what I love about that
shit.
Those are the guys who win all these.
Who's that?
Not Bill bixby.
What the hell's the name of that guy?
The guy with the.
He's been riding a bicycle out here
forever.
Solar panels in Bill Bixby,
a Ed Begley Jr.
I'm bad with the names and show.
Yeah,
he,
he's goIng to be at the apocalypse.
Comes.
He's going to be fucked.
I have this theory that people who
gather all this shit for it.
If you don't have a,
you need a militia because if you don't,
all you're doing is you're just turning
your house into a supply room.
A target for the toughest guys who'd
come down the block and then just take
it from you.
My car,
my car has like walkie talkies in it.
It's got fucking like every single
thing.
I like sleeping bags just in case I've
had to escape this city real quick,
but it's starting to get retarded.
Like I haven't like batteries that could
recharge by this sign and stuff like
that.
Do you realize the level of heads up
that you.
How on the inside you'd have to be that
this entire city wouldn't be like
gridlock of people leaving?
Yeah.
Oh,
this city would be the worst ever.
They don't even know how many people in
la.
That's why I won't fill out the census.
They're like,
you know,
filling out the census so you fit the
fuck is the point.
There's about $20,
million mexicans that you don't have a
count on,
like they literally have no idea how
many mexicans are here.
It's fucking just a flat out guests and
I'm not shitting on mexicans.
Yeah,
I would do the goddamn same thing.
My grandparents were immigrants.
I would be.
I got no problem with immigration.
I don't even believe in countries.
I think the whole thing is ridiculous.
I mean,
I think if they came over here,
yeah,
I would fuck things up,
but you know what?
It's really.
That's how it's supposed to be.
You're not supposed to keep people
impoverished in a shitty place just
because you know you,
you know,
you claim this patch of dirt and don't
let them over here.
I think that's ridiculous.
You know,
if there weren't countries and you were
just allowed to just sort of cruise
around,
like where would you go?
That would be the problem was things
would.
they would level out.
The problem is you let people go and
move to wherever they want and people
are always going to move to the place
where it's better and they're going to
abandon their shitty place,
but if you don't allow them,
they have to stay in a shitty place and
make their shitty place better,
which they never going to fucking do.
So you ensure that there's always going
to be levels of people.
The only way to keep levels other than
that is just fuCking be heavily armed.
You have to be armed to the teeth.
Your whole town would have to be an
armory,
you know,
like literally if you wanted to keep
people out,
you would have to like constantly be
shooting people constantly.
THe weapons
they have now,
it's,
I just love how they've been stealing
money from our paychecks to basically
invent these weapons that will make it
impossible for.
They'll never be another revolution.
No,
other than,
you know,
is doing it right.
Is that guy out there in the carolinas,
the blackwater guy,
whatever.
Whatever the fuck it's called when we're
talking about it,
that bill bixby guy on that fucking dude
who he buys like oldf sixteens and old
tanks and he basically,
they're saying if he wanted to,
could take over the white house in all
of dc by the time they fucking
responded.
Who the fuck Is this guy?
He's fucking iza.
No
black water.
So this is a private contractor.
I believe.
Jesus christ.
I can't believe you haven't heard of the
guy.
Well,
I know the.
There's a one
comedy central has a development deal
with.
He's still,
he's the final guy in show business.
He was funny.
They would do it.
Yeah.
He has like a.
He's got like his own thing.
It.
Did it come up,
prince,
isn't that a guy that got popped for
murder?
He's uh,
he's being processed from.
Well,
he,
he's the guy.
He actually has his own hit basically.
I,
from what I've heard,
has his own militia and actually hired.
He gets hired out by the us government
for them to go over there when they want
to do some covert extra filthy shit.
This is the worst.
I have a friend who went over there who
worked for who he worked for blackwater.
He went over there twice to two seconds
ago.
You asked me who they were.
No,
I know who blackwater is.
I don't know who this guy is that stores
all these weapons.
And the head guy.
Well I have a friend who he was,
he was a sniper in the marines and when
he got out he went back over.
He went back,
I think he went to both Afghanistan and
Iraq,
but he definitely went to Afghanistan.
He went twice for money because he was
opening up a gym and mixed martial arts
gym and he needed some cash.
So It just went over there for a few
months and he made some ridiculous
amount of money,
like something like $10,000
a month or something like that.
It was a lot of money.
So for him,
and they'd go over for a couple months,
make 30 grand,
you know,
did he do like the stereotypical go up
in the bell tower he had.
He was in a bell tower.
There was times where he was in the
tower.
Uh,
it's erik prince is the owner of a
blackwater,
so I'm guessing that's,
that's the guy that's in trouble,
right?
Right.
And he's like fleeing and he's in
trouble.
They had to take him down because he got
too powerful because he could basically,
that guy could write out any sort of
uprising,
any sort of craziness to me went crazy.
Whatever.
It's just like,
yeah,
well I got guns and an endless bag of a
snow peas,
a bunch of mercenary loyalty based
forever.
You know,
you've been paying these guys to do all
these for you overseas.
They're all murderers for you and you
know,
you keep those guys on the line and say,
hey,
you know,
we're gonna run this shit,
I'm going to take care of you.
You take care of me,
you know,
semper fi motherfucker,
black water for life,
the whole deal.
And then they go down,
they can defend it.
But then when it always ends up
happening is eventually is somebody
always wants you to title.
So someone would want to be him and
that's how it goes down.
It goes down to Mexico,
the drugstore,
you know,
it's just a matter of time before
something happens with one of those
fucking guys.
You've got a guy who's got that much
power,
that many jets and fucking machine guns
and tanks and shit.
It's going to get a little nutty.
I.
You start using them.
You know what I mean?
It's like you bought a bag of fireworks.
Just going to stick them in the corner.
you better wait till the next 4th of
July.
You're not occasionally going to light
off and mad.
oh,
they like to use them.
Have you ever seen,
this is the first time in human history
or rather in the history of the United
States,
so we've had to deal with mercenaries.
We haven't had merce rent mercenaries in
this country in a long,
long,
long fucking time.
This whole like giant mercenary
corporation sort of a thing.
This is very recent.
This is just chaney and bush.
They didn't use birth scenarios during
clinton.
There was no mercenaries during the
jimmy carter days.
You know,
this is,
this is some crazy shit.
Chaney and bush,
the hall and oates.
The fact that they can hire these people
to go do shit that you're not supposed
to do.
They can ship.
It's not in the geneva convention.
shit.
That's totally who I know we have,
but we haven't been doing this openly,
you know,
company to do it.
They go,
well,
I think it's definitely for that,
but I think it's like when wrestling
finally just came out and said it's
sports entertainment.
They like,
oh right.
You know,
we hired these guys for some filthy
shit.
What he wanted from us.
it's entertaining though,
right?
yeah.
And they changed it to wwe.
He it the name of black water.
What does it now?
I don't know.
Something short.
Something happier.
Bunny rabbits incorporated clearwater
fresh,
fresh drinking water for everybody.
Babies r us.
Yeah.
Arrowhead.
We love the children.
that's what they changed it to.
Yeah,
they're.
I dunno.
It's.
There's two schools of thought.
One is the world is a fucked up place.
Look at what's going on in africa.
Look what's going on in the middle east.
Don't you want somebody over there
protecting you?
They're just trying to keep America
cool.
Keep our stAndard alive.
Keep our standard of living the same.
I see that argument too,
but then you know,
you see the also the other argument,
I don't believe in that whole that those
guys have to live the way they live.
So I live the way I live.
It's still those guys on top can have as
much as they have.
Well that's definitely much more likely.
that's what was pissing me off the other
day like,
but I think they also do keep it is,
it's a twofold argument.
One,
it's like they keep conflict going on
and the more conflict that keep going
on,
the more we're going to need government
and we're more,
we're going to need protection when
that's been proven that the create
conflict in other parts of the world in
order to control different regions.
They'll arm someone if their enemy is,
you know,
the other side and they'll fuck with
things and they manipulated it.
But all that bullshit where they go,
where they say,
well they justify like sweatshop labor
and moving factories out of the us and
you know,
they just went around the unions and
then they,
they just justified
it by saying,
you know,
and they always say in order to compete
in a global economy,
it's like fuck you.
It's like in order for you to have to
get another yacht,
you know what I mean?
You can't legally pay a child,
you know,
whatever the fuck they pay over there.
I'm in America.
Yeah,
you can't do it.
So they just went around all of that
shit and then they stuck all of
everybody's in cubicles.
Now the to is day because we were just
talking about the military before.
We were talking about the military.
Now we're talking about,
I'm talking about corporations,
I'm talking about big business where I
think corporations are at the annual
every quarter they have to show a profit
there at the end of what,
of legal ways to do it.
So now they're just straight up
beginning to steal like my fucking bank.
That's taking 28 bucks a month out of my
account for no reason.
I didn't even notice.
You know,
on the road one of those fucking
accounts.
You just have a couple hundred.
But I finally said,
dude,
why you take a 28 bucks out of this?
And they did it on the.
On the laptop.
Oh yeah,
we shouldn't be doing that.
All right,
well I've had this for five years.
Let's go back.
And they go on.
Unfortunately sir,
our records only go back four months.
He had that convenient.
I bet if I was getting 28 bucks from
you,
you know the other way,
I bet they would fucking go back to the
sixties.
SaMe thing happened to me and it was
three months and this is what they said
to me.
I said,
what if I bring in all my records?
What if I bring in all my records?
And then they go,
so it was still,
we're only going to reimburse you for
months.
I go,
I got that.
That's,
that's ridiculous.
and then the guy at the bank was,
well the bank looks at it like that's on
you,
right?
Because I didn't send you to pay
attention that they're stealing,
stealing from me,
paying attention.
What he was basically saying what he was
basically saying was lawyer up.
Yeah.
So you're up buddy.
Go ahead.
Pretty much how it works is that's why
you have 30 days,
you know for credit card,
you have 30 days to return shit.
You have 30 days to make sure all these
charges are correct.
Once you get past 30 days and then
you're pretty much screwed.
So they,
they do other shit where if you say one
of these guys,
I pay off my balance every month and you
think you're getting them,
this is what they do is if a,
if you pay it three days before it's a.
This guy was telling me it ends up being
late because they send it somewhere else
to be processed.
They deliberately,
they artificially delay it.
So by the time it does get to the right,
it's messed up.
And this is another one of those other
things.
Someone told me that in a starbucks and
then I got,
I got,
I got three quarters away through the
sentence and I realized I didn't have
any official.
Right.
I do know that there has to be something
our official because nowadays you can
write a check and within hours that
check clears your bank and I'm like
that's a check and it's going through in
two hours.
And they're like,
yes,
this is,
you know,
technology has changed in the banking
system so this is new.
But yet if you try to pay something off
or do something like that,
it's like immediately or.
I mean it takes like three days on your
transfer funds takes like three days.
What is it makes no sense.
It can be bad artificial,
however long they can hold onto your
money.
They make interest off your money too.
So I guess if you think about that,
if they hold onto your money and extra
few days before they do something and
you add that up
over,
you know,
the million people they have in their
bank and the 365 days a year,
that practice probably nets them a
significant amount of money if you look
at 28 bucks from every shit
may who doesn't check for a fucking
year.
And I didn't notice when it until it
went under a thousand bucks because I
knew I had a thousand something in
there.
It was one of the thing counts I had
back east.
Um,
so I came out here and I was always
meaning to close that out.
And I was like,
I had like 1200 bucks is something in it
and I don't.
And then all of a sudden I'm out here
for like a year and a half and all a
sudden I get my statement and it was
like down to like 900 something bucks
and that is on me.
It is on me because I didn't realize
that your bank could fucking steal from
you.
And then just say,
well,
you know,
go fuck yourself.
That's your fault.
Tell you what,
we'll give you like 80,
90 bucks back.
No,
they gave you.
They gave you like three months back.
I don't even know if they did the guy
steady what?
I walked out disgusted and then the nba
final started read their circus and I
started watching that and I never
followed up.
There's actually something that just
passed you guys,
especially the audience might want to
check this out.
I used to be a credit card,
like a bank or a credit card could like
if you had an ax,
seven charges go through at the same
time,
they can take out all those seven
charges and in charge you seven
overdraft fees.
That's how they used to be able to do
it.
But something just passed recently that
you could tell your credit cards and
your bank that you.
If there's no money in your account,
you are not allowed to pull money out.
so they're tryIng to trick you into
signing and going,
no,
let's keep it the old way.
So they'll call you up or they'll tell
you like,
hey,
you know,
you want to make sure all these charges
go through,
right?
Yeah.
Well you need to accept the.
That letter was that new letter is so
don't blow it off till all your credit
card companies know that if there is no
money in the account,
you don't want it to go through and
you'll save yourself all those over.
You'll,
you'll never have an overdraft again.
Forcing overdraft fees on people.
They're trying to.
They're trying to go back to the old way
where you'd have seven things go through
like a $3 charge and then you get
charged $39 for an overdraft fee.
You're like,
well why did it go through?
I had no money in my account,
you know,
made a deposit to cover it.
They let they input the deposit last,
right?
And then bam,
bam,
bam.
And they nail it.
Well,
it deposit takes 90 days to go through
where the charge only takes three
seconds.
Yeah.
So sorry.
I know,
I understand.
There's nothing we can do.
I love that.
That's what you always get.
There's nothing we can do.
I'm sorry.
I don't know.
I like,
I got on a plane ticket the other day
and I show up and all of a sudden I
don't have a seat reservation.
Had one on the way out.
Well it's oversold.
Well I didn't do that.
And then the.
And then the lady has like an attitude
with me and it's like,
what the fuck?
I spent full $500 bucks.
They asked me where I wanted to sit.
I picked out the fucking seat and I was
told to have a reservation.
And then you oversaw
with a car.
You.
If somebody pays for a car and you go,
okay,
your car is waiting for you and the guy
comes down.
No,
no,
it was oversold.
I oversold.
It should be against the law.
I,
I wanted to make sure I sold the car.
So I sold it twice.
Yeah,
but that's not even as bad because you
can get in your
car and fucking drive home.
Be imagine if they go to interrupt you.
I know we oversold whatever car you
have.
So they had to come and take yours and
took it away and you're fucking sitting
in your house going,
yeah,
but I,
I have to go to the airport.
I'm sorry sir.
There's nothing we could do.
How can they do that?
I don't.
I don't care if they're losing money.
How can they sell more seats than there
are seats?
That should be.
I think they fought.
They figured out a way to have like 10
years ago when used to go on the road,
how many times was the seat next to
empty?
All the time.
Occasionally you'd get the whole row and
curl up back in the good old days.
The good old good old days.
When does that happen now?
And it never happens now because they'll
always say like,
the cancel flights together.
There you go.
Don't give a fuck.
That's right.
And they'll just give away tickets to
people that were like,
hey,
you get a free ticket if you,
you know,
just wait til the next flight.
So they're not actually overselling it
because they don't get rid of those
tickets for you.
You know what though?
The way I look at it that you have to
have fucking airlines or I wouldn't have
a job.
I literally need airlines to get along.
No,
no.
I'm not saying people don't.
I'm not against airlines.
I'm not telling me I have whatever.
Then I don't,
I,
I hate that too.
But whatever the fuck they have to do to
stay in business for us.
For comics.
Could you imagine if you had a fucking
drive to all your gigs?
Could you imagine if you have a drive?
If you had a New York gig?
Okay.
I got a gig on friday in New York,
so it's monday.
I'm packing up my car.
Could you fucking imagine?
No,
you don't be great.
Would be immediately how regional.
All our comedy boston jokes.
When I,
uh,
there was a chain like seven slash 11
called christie's.
You remember that?
I'll never forget the first time I did a
gig outside of boston.
I went to,
I think it was like New Hampshire and I
had some stupid joke about winning the
lottery.
How nobody respects you that you move
into a rich neighborhood and they're
like,
what do you do?
I'm a doctor,
I did this.
I'm a brain surgeon.
What do you do?
I say,
oh,
I went to christie's,
like,
you know,
meaning I got a lottery ticket.
It wasn't even a good fucking job to
begin with.
And then I went up to New Hampshire and
I told the joke and I'm like,
I went to christie's.
That was the first time I used to
reference that nobody fucking got.
And I remember that high five.
You were gone by then the high five gig
where it was at the top of the only
skyscraper.
And like manchester,
New Hampshire.
Yeah.
And I,
I
balls.
I used to do a lot of local material
when I was living in boston because it
would kill,
you know,
so he jokes about girls and revere with
a big bulletproof hairdos and yeah,
a lot of like regional shit.
And then when I would go on the road it
was like,
I was disarmed,
like none of my references would work.
I will tell revere beach joke and you
would get like,
recognition,
laughter and boston,
but when you're on the road,
they just,
okay,
where's the joke?
I remember those guys and they'd have
to,
they'd go down to jersey and they'd be
like,
what's the equivalent to revere beach
down here?
Yeah,
you got,
you got to regionalize all your
references.
The only time that's happened lately,
lately is up.
If I go over to europe and uh,
I was saying to somebody the other day,
one of the few things that,
not only,
I didn't have to change,
but fucking was a reference to a,
um,
a ric flair.
Really ric flair.
That's how big those guys are.
Wow.
Fucking destroyed in london,
dublin and glasgow.
Scotland.
Well,
they have a lot of american,
uh,
american culture over there.
England especially.
I find it english american comedians
translate way quicker to england in
england due to american.
Yeah.
We're,
we're like,
yeah,
we're stuck with snobs over here.
We hear like a british accent.
English.
Yeah.
But I mean,
but I'm saying like the comedy doesn't
translate as well.
They have a very specific type of humor.
But they get ours,
you know?
Yeah.
I don't know what I feel like I felt
when british comedians,
comedians,
comedian over there,
I either love him or I not only do,
I not like them,
but I feel like they're like 15 years
behind the time,
which is
because nice over there.
It's almost like the attitude they have
as a country,
as a culture hampers their ability to
stand up because real standup,
there's a part of real estate.
And it was like,
what the fuck are you doing?
You know,
they don't have that.
They don't,
they don't get.
But somehow it comes out in the music
though.
Like it always seems like,
you know everything from like the sex
pistols to fuckin ozzy osborne,
these elders,
these baroque angry fucking dudes
fighting too.
There's a lot of tough mma guys would
come out of the uk somehow.
I'm trying to think of.
They're more poLite.
There's something about their humor.
It's just like,
you know what It is?
It's cheeky.
Isn't that the word that she is cheeky?
I don't know.
What it is is just some of them were
really good,
but some of them are just,
it just doesn't,
you know,
and I think first of all,
those style of comedy that you and I
come from too,
you get very spoiled at a certain
particular type of colleague.
Boston comedy is a very specific kind of
comedy.
If you stop and think about how many
good comics have come from boston,
you know,
jay leno came from boston.
Steven wright came from boston guys that
people don't know that it probably
better than 90 percent of the fucking
people that are like big name comics.
Like gavin don gavin's,
one of the funniest guys ever walked the
face of the earth.
Yeah,
he's,
he's a monster.
He's a,
I think it's all like the east coast,
I think all the way down to like dc,
the amount of guys.
But I.
But I also think because we're from
boston doesn't have to leave.
They didn't leave.
Those guys stayed there.
No one left boston.
The big monsters.
Steve sweeney,
kenny rogers sang those.
Don gavin,
Mike Donovan when I was a kid.
Okay.
And I will,
when I first started doing open mics
there and those guys were all the
national headliners or the local
headlines rather they'd be at nick's and
they'd be it.
The connection.
I remember sitting there watching those
guys and they would have like some like
national guy would come through like
billy crystal and billy crystal would
come through and they would put on dawn
gavin,
steve sweeney and fucking and lenny
clarke in a row and then bring up billy
crystal.
And they did it on purpose.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
They knew that the level of comedy was
so high there.
And these guys were doing 20 minutes
tight to say 20 minutes to do it for
doing.
A lot of them were doing local
references.
Dude,
I don't give up.
If you put on for local headliners in
front of me,
a farm on the rug fucked.
You're fucked.
You're fucked for first couple of
minutes until you can get them into your
groove.
But people love local shit.
AnD boston,
especially boston is such a city that in
love with being from boston.
So it's done.
It was one of my favorites.
His name doesn't get brought up,
but not a novel topic that he used to do
that joke about,
uh,
had some,
he,
his comedy was so blue collar and I was
coming up,
uh,
you know,
working in warehouses and stuff.
It was where my,
both my parents were professional,
white collar,
but I,
I was a moron,
so fucked up in schools.
So I had like blue collar job.
So his comedy was just right out over
the place.
He did something.
He had some sort of back and forth with
the boss and he made this reference,
you know,
basically tell him the boss to go fuck
himself.
He said I'll take a 20 minutes,
shit on the clock if I want to.
And I fucking fell out because it was
always that lazy fuck wouldn't help
unload the trucks.
He had every god damn trick in the book
and how to somehow make that eight hour
day go by.
And one of them was when he had grabbed
the herald and the globe to go take a
shit and it would somehow take like
fucking 40 minutes everyday.
Donovan was a,
here's another one.
He's a master.
There was a bunch of guys that were
around back then.
I mean,
they're still around.
I'm sure don,
wouldn't you?
If you live in boston,
you could probably find them headline
and somewhere and he's still doing
comedy,
I'm sure.
Right?
I know he ran a foul into the irs for a
bit.
He owed a lot of those guys that were
working for cash for a long time.
They weren't paying taxes on it.
I didn't hear anything about that.
They were all up to date.
I don't know what you're talking about.
YeaH,
you're right.
You know what?
I miss her.
I think those,
those guys out in long island.
I think some of them did.
I miss.
Oh,
here's another one that doesn't get
brought up.
Teddy bears.
Ron,
do you ever get a chance to teddy,
but holy shit,
that guy was good.
Let me tell you something.
I saw that guy in 1988.
I was at an open mic night and it was
one of the first time.
So I thought about quitting comedy.
It was an open mic night and I went up
and I,
you know,
I did my little five minutes of fucking
nonsense,
stupid,
terrible,
bad comedy,
just trying to make people laugh,
didn't know what the fuck I was doing
and didn't go so good.
You know,
those early sets.
It was like one of my third or fourth
sets,
so not so good,
clumsy,
you know,
maybe one lab and then I fuck it up with
a sweat punchline and I just didn't
known as known teddy bears.
Ron goes up and
so fucking smooth,
smooth and relaxed and the way he would
talk just like mesmerizing and I had
heard about his tonight show,
fucking said he had just done the
tonight show and somebody had a video of
it and they played the video and he
plays the piano.
Does like this,
talks about commercials and he plays the
piano and talk someone.
It's so fucking smooth and so good.
You would look at them and go,
okay,
this guy's going to be gigantic.
This is going to be bigger than than
robin williams.
He's going to be the biggest stand comic
at the country.
Never left boston to stayed.
They all stay in.
I don't.
Yeah,
they will.
They would.
It was like townies but a but comedians,
but that they all got work.
They all got work in boston.
They didn't have to leave.
See when they were working at nick's
comedy stop and they were working at,
you know,
stitches and all these different clubs.
They could hop around from club to club.
Like there's a that,
that,
that documentary in France.
Alameda did stand up,
stood up and,
and you know,
lenny clarke talks about all the
different sets that he did.
He would do all these different sets of
nyt now.
We'd go from here to there and are there
and they're,
they're enclosed.
They'd be making 1500 bucks a night.
Yeah.
And he just hire a driver.
Has to wait outside and do all the sets.
What I love about those guys is there
was almost like a height requirement to
like,
they will all like fucking six,
two,
three huge guys.
And they could like literally would have
like a keg of beer over one shoulder and
like an eight ball in their hand.
And we'll just be going from club to
club destroying and flow all the way
just to keep that buzz going.
And then.
And then at the end of the night do it.
I heard some fuck that.
That backroom at nick's man.
Someone offered to pay me and coke.
What?
Yeah.
They would offer to pay you in coke.
That was the deal.
Did they do coke?
Oh no,
we can pay in coke.
No,
I'll take.
I'll take fuck.
Like I thought that was a joke.
I didn't realize they pay you and coke.
They will offer to pay you and coke and
a lot of guys.
Did a lot of guys get some of the money
in coke because I guess are comedians
and porn stars to two careers.
I couldn't get paid and coke if I had to
come down to it.
I would say probably bands too.
Probably a lot of bands.
A portion of the boxers back in the day
they'd give you some chips.
You ever see that?
I know it's just a photo op thing.
Be able to see that,
that great picture of sonny liston.
Yeah.
Where he's a.
It looks like he just knocked somebody
out and he's sitting there still in his
box of trunks.
Hands taped up.
I think his hands were on,
but I haven't had to been a promotional.
Even even those mob guys be like,
come on sunday,
let's get this shit.
Don't you think the starting on boston
was like one of the best places you
could have ever chose to begin your
comedy career?
I think about that a lot.
So whenever I think about that,
because when did You start?
What year?
I started in march of 92.
Uh,
it was like twentY three,
almost 24,
so I started a little bit late and I
remember just some of the times like
when I've gone on the road and uh,
and you meet the young,
the up and coming guys like,
yeah,
the comedy scene here sucks and blah
blah blah blah blah.
Like,
like it sucks sO bad,
like don't even know what to do.
And you always tell them what,
just go out and start a room.
Like some of them like the scene so bad
they don't even think of doing that.
It's like what even start roaming
psycho,
pick a fucking sports bar that does no
business on a monday,
tuesday and tell them that you're going
to get people in here,
you know,
lie to him that you know you're going to
get people to come in to watch these
fucking open microbes do five minutes
each day.
The first time I ate my fucking balls on
stage,
I was still in this place like kelly's
something or rather and reading or north
reading,
it doesn't exist anymore.
This comedian Jack Lynch booked it and
there would literally be like a bruins
game on
tv and they wouldn't shut the game off.
Fuck no,
no.
You got to do comedy over the game.
And The volume for the game was still
onto.
yeah,
a lot of those gigs down the cape.
I did a lot of those gigs and you'd find
out the fucking game was on why you got
there.
Like fuck the game.
I'm going to leave the game on.
That was like an always an issue.
You're going to lead the game and if
they said we're going to turn the game
off,
they would turn the game on.
Everybody goes,
what the fuck you fucking shot.
Who shot in the foot?
And then you would have to go do comedy
for a bunch of people were angry at you
for shutting the gate.
It was brutal.
and I remember,
yeah,
the second question,
other than,
are you going to,
uh,
are you going to shut the game off?
Is,
is there a stage?
That was another thing.
So you jusT stand.
You just stand right over there too.
and I remember doing a gig.
this is how green we,
where it was me,
al del,
benny,
patrice o'neil,
and I want to say dane cook was on it
and we was Bobby Kelly,
I think it was his gig that he booked.
We were so green and years later I
finally figured it out.
They gave us this microphone.
It was a lapel mic.
So he had to go up and do comedy with
just like a lapel on,
like we were doing letterman but we were
so green.
We didn't know that you clipped it on
cereal.
All standing there.
Holding.
Holding a lapel mic.
I remember patrice.
He's like fucking six five.
Hold on because I remember.
That's right.
Dell benny benny was hosting is like,
what the fuck is up with this mike?
This is the smallest mike ever.
Look,
I'll put up my hand in his mouth and
we're all laughing at them like yeah,
what a half fast fucking gig.
And we were so stupid that we didn't
understand what it was and like he would
let it out,
would bring me up and then hand me the
mic,
like a tea cup at this pinkies out
picking out and that would just be like,
hey,
keep it golf out.
And my dad was.
He was preTty nuts growing up with like
three fingers up in the air holding this
thing.
Have you done standup on a talk show
with a lapel mic?
Yeah,
I actually really like it.
Do you ever thought about going Bobby
Brown style onstage?
Y'all ready for this?
I know chris titus does that titus,
whereas like a headgear thing,
I don't like that.
I don't like jackets and I don't like
and I hate,
I don't know how you do comedy,
but the jacket on,
I don't mind it if it's cold.
If it's cold,
I'll wear a jacket.
Zipped bottle.
I can wear a zip up,
but the sport coat,
it just doesn't move with the shirt.
I wore a sport coat the first time I
went on stage because I thought that's
how you're supposed to dress out of
sport.
Coat with the sleeves rolled up like
this.
I was talking about that miami vice tee
shirt and a wacky tee shirt.
Tee shirt with like a silly smile on it
because I thought that's how you and a
pen.
I had like a button or something on my
fucking sports coat.
Did you get to see chris rock on linda
the other day?
Just.
That was so great.
What happened?
It just fucking with j dot lee with last
time I was here there's a dude with red
hair and started saying that kevin the
band guy and the guy's like,
man,
that's cold.
Because it was pretty funny.
He attacked.
He was uncomfortable.
He kept on going into it.
You could tell jay when you're like,
that is one of the most amazing things
I've ever seen.
How he got that show back?
Oh yeah.
It's crazy.
I don't.
I don't disagree with them.
Now,
look,
you know everybody puts it this way.
Look,
the guy was on top,
he was fucking number one,
number one,
and they come along and say we're going
to lose you or they were going to lose
conan unless we give him the tonight
show,
so we want to give him the tonight show.
And he was like,
whaT?
Fucking really?
You've got to take my gang away from me.
And so he goes,
okay,
all right.
I'm a and under duress.
He offers to give up the gig in five
years,
but he's number one number.
Brilliant.
I think he's brilliant.
He was number one,
so he gets kicked off.
They put this new guy,
the new guy is bombing.
He's eaten dick.
Okay.
That's what no one wants to talk about.
Conan o'brian on the tonight show wasn't
that good?
But that's bullshit because linda is
doing the exact same ratings right now
as as.
No,
no,
no.
What we're going to go back to that
dropped substantially.
It dropped substantially from where it
was before.
From where it was when linda was hosting
it to conan.
Hold on,
hold on a second.
They fuck conan by not letting them do
any of us.
Couldn't do the masturbating.
Bear couldn't do all these different,
different sketches.
Couldn't do triuMph.
The insult dog couldn't do any of that
shit.
Alright.
Because it's 11:00
show they fucked if when jay leno got
the tonight show,
if he had to follow Johnny Carson
bombing for an hour.
Totally right about that.
But that's like if a comedian bombs in
front of you,
right for an half hour in front of you.
I mean you got to jack the tonight show
because of the tonight show was always
the late night show where guys would go
on and all the guests would go on and it
would be like an important spot.
Will the 10:00
spot became just as important.
So he was like siphoning off guests,
like,
you know,
you couldn't have a guy who's promoting,
mel gibson goes on jay leno show and
then goes on tonight show as well.
No,
you're only gonna have one of the other
is all about with atlanta.
So the brilliance of it was jay bombing
actually fucked conan conan here.
We had this show for like six months
before they were started going like,
all right,
let's get this guy out.
And he got it back now I think,
uh,
I think taking,
it was a brilliant away from it.
I think it was a brilliant,
brilliant.
The way jpl played it was absolutely
brilliant and I don't know,
I'm not saying bond on purpose,
but the way he played it,
like,
yeah,
sure,
I'll do it.
And then the twelfth hour,
yeah I'm going to leave but I'm not
retiring.
and then they freaked the fuck out.
So like he knows,
I don't know how we look at it.
Like I understand jay being like,
look,
I the number one show,
what are you kicking me off?
Or he's totally right about that.
But I also,
I don't look at conan like he failed,
like calling got fucked.
He got fucked.
I completely agree.
But what I'm saying is you've got to
realize that jay leno had the number one
spot.
He was number one in the late night wars
before they gave it to conan.
So why would he
give a fuck if they gave the show to
call and offered it back to him?
Why would he not take it him?
I,
I don't,
you know,
but everybody's making it out.
Like jay is this asshole for taking
conan's job.
I go,
gone and took his job.
Conan's not a,
he's not a poor man.
he's a rich man.
Like we're really
worry about the most fucked up about it
is.
And keeps saying don't feel bad for me.
He made it.
He made a great little a.
He said a great little thing on his last
episode.
He said,
don't be cynical,
you know,
blah,
blah blah.
I hate people who were cynically said
this really positive thing,
don't feel bad for me.
Played fucking free bird with the band.
Went out like a man and that was it.
He's never bitched about it or any of
that type of shit.
Fucking Million dollars.
I think that was super smooth things
over.
I see.
No matter what kona does,
he's an asshole.
No,
I'm gay,
but he gave a lot of that money.
He gave a lot of that money out to
people he worked with.
No,
they want it to fucking move back.
He felt bad for those guys.
The only thing that I find annoying
about jay leno is acting as though he
isn't a shrewd businessman.
That whole.
I mean,
I know I'm going to do that,
but that's how he wants to portray
himself.
That's fine.
That's what I'm saying.
That's the only thing that fucking
annoys you about.
The whole thing
annoyed me was when everybody's making a
big deal at jay's taking conan's job,
but conan took jay's job,
took johnny's job.
He fucking forced him out.
Did he really?
I don't know about that.
How did you force him out of that
fucking book?
I read.
I read the late shift.
Had a fucking book I read.
I read though the fucking late shift.
Plus,
I read how much people pay attention to
these late night.
No,
but this.
This is the thing though,
if if,
if jay only got,
first of all,
jay without johnny bomb and in front of
them going on,
if they're like fucking er and seinfeld
and all those hit shows,
do it still took him 18 months.
Remember,
letterman was kicking the shit out of
it.
Yeah.
Yes.
Until you got hugh grant on,
right?
It took them 18 months,
only six fucking months and he's got to
follow the previous host eaten his balls
for a half hour in front of them.
It was,
it was bullshit.
They should have just this idea.
It was a ridiculous idea.
They were just afraid to let go and
conan was like,
look,
I want the fucking tonight show.
And they didn't want to give it to them.
They go back and forth and so they give
it to them to get shot.
That jason's numbers we're going to drop
in.
FIve years is going to be pushing 60.
Who's you know,
who's going to want to watch?
This is the dumbest thing ever.
A guy's gonna.
What did Johnny Carson got better as he
got older?
That's ridiculous.
This is what I think.
I think kona is going to be way better
off on a network that just lets them do
whatever the fuck he wants.
I think tbs show,
dude,
he owns that show.
He's going to be so much that he's
brilliant and you know w when conan is
at its best,
when you get to see how funny it is,
like you ever see that the one's gifts
he did about a baseball.
A bunch of people who play baseball like
a,
like 18 hundreds.
Baseball.
They have like a vent.
They were vintage clothes.
They make the wrong and I saw this
fucking genius.
Hilarious because he just goes balls out
and it's just him,
you know,
it's just him being funny.
If I guarantee you they fucked with them
too much.
When they switched them to 11:00,
they probably cut all the,
the,
like the meat in the.
Anything controversial out of his
monologues or out of his sketches.
They probably stopped him from doing a
lot of shit.
Yeah.
And he saId when he left,
don't feel bad for me and people are
still saying that he's a,
he's whining,
which I don't get.
I mean,
he did.
He did jokes about an in,
in his model level.
What fuck you supposed to do.
Yeah.
It's just sitting there talking about
maybe you're going to get replaced.
She's supposed to go out there and be
like,
hey,
do you see the earthquake in Haiti?
It was funny when the,
uh,
had a car,
I think it was a bugatti,
a Million dollar car.
And they play the rolling stones,
get no satisfaction.
And there was a sketch just to spend
money.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Which I'm sure is bullshit,
but it's still pretty funny.
That's pretty funny that he did it like
that.
Speaking of that,
I was watching one of those car
auctions,
uh,
the other,
yesterday.
And I'm just sitting there looking at
all these awesome old cars that I would
love to own.
And as the price kept going up and up
and up on some fucking like ferrari,
it just was just,
I,
I started to resent the people in the
crowd like at these,
the bankers.
Is this what they did with the trulia?
Who the fuck has the money?
There was some,
if you can bring it up for your
listeners,
there's a fucking car in 1958 that bmw
made.
It was designed by a guy who actually
was in refrigerating or whatever.
Literally the front of the car fucking
opens up like a refrigerator and you
walk out the front and there's one back
door.
It's like a mini car.
Be a 1950.
I think it's a bmw 600.
A 319.
There it is.
Bring that thing up.
Okay.
What the fuck?
It's a hunk of shit.
It's the ice.
I s e t t a 1915.
Oh,
I've seen that before.
I seen one of those little mini.
It looks just like it.
There's one in this european magazines
spin around so he can see it.
So basicallY I guess got one wiper in
the front.
It's a five year old kid,
get licensed to drive the thing.
So this guy paid like 11 grand for like,
hey,
you know,
I'm hoping to get 30,
35,
42 fucking thing.
Went for 67,
five,
$67,000
for that $67,500
for that hunk of shit.
Guys like jay leno closed car collected
dudes.
They like to have like old cars,
like rare old cars with jay's monies
clean.
He didn't stand up.
He's doinG that.
I'm talking about these,
these other fucking guys.
It's like if you're not famous.
No.
Who's in the audience where they got
their money from?
What are they all invented?
Playstation.
Do they own farms?
They fucking.
They sell lcd electronics.
Who knows?
That's what I'm saying.
Well,
let me ask you,
what are these fucking banker?
Spend all that money I'll do.
They took a trillion dollars.
Where did it go?
The at the fucking car auctions.
The aMazing thing about that whole
banker thing,
the whole bailout was that those guys
still wanted bonuses.
They still wanted bonuses even though
their bank failed and the government had
to give them billions of dollars though
fucking
houses.
They got the bailout money that kept it.
Then they're fucking guys like me.
Twenty eight bucks a month.
Our records only go back four months and
they kept the money and they got the
fucking houses back to do again.
They're going to do it again,
is sweating.
They should get the death penalty.
You touch a kid,
you fuck with an animal or you make old
people eat dog food for the last 15
years of their life when they thought
they were going to live in their
houseboat or their dreams,
you should be fucking murdered publicly.
Bernie madoff did start him.
Bernie madoff is a lightweight.
He's a lightweight,
fucked over million.
That's nothing,
but he was the only fucked over six
people.
These guys fucked over a whole country.
It sex.
Look it up.
It's on wikipedia.
Now.
Bernie madoff,
bernie madoff.
It's a sacrificial lamb.
That guy should be killed too,
but he was the guy like.
The funny thIng is is people look at
bernie madoff and they look like they.
Well,
they took down one of the bankers who
not a banker,
he was,
he was like a fucking an investment
bank.
I don't want to talk in a bus.
He was like one of those private guys
like joel,
I know what to do with your fucking
money.
He didn't have like an atm that you
could use.
He was,
he was one of those guys,
the smith barney guys,
right.
I fucked a lot of employees is stupid.
well,
he fucked a bunch of people that should
have known better.
You know,
there was a lot of people that were in
the business.
That's when I just liked it.
I always thought fucked other rich
people.
Yeah,
we fucked up most rich.
But he fucked also a bunch of,
like different,
uh,
jewish,
groups that had charities.
He fucked charities over.
He fucked a lot of people over.
But uh,
he was,
he was fucking over people that were in
the whole,
the,
the industry,
the financial industry.
So they should have known what he was
doing was fucked up and they still will
but look at the returns and so they just
dove in even though none of it made
sense.
There was people that were calling for
an investigation into his,
his from like years and years ago,
and they ignored it and just kept going.
I think I was the fucking head of the
fcc at one point in time or what does it
change?
What was he the head of nasdaq?
Was it nasdaq?
He was the head of,
I think he was the head of nasdaq and
the not fcc.
He's the head of nasdaq and this fucking
guy goes on to be the biggest ponzi
scheme mastermind in the history of the
country.
I mean that's pretty incredible.
A guy that like worked in the system,
he must've known that it's impossible to
figure it out.
like I always,
I never paid attention.
Like I look at the stock market,
I see all those numbers going back and
forth and I'm wondering what the fuck is
all that?
What does that even mean?
You know,
somebody knows to crap table.
It seems like it's all bullshit,
but look,
obviously there's this alan greenspan
guy seems very bright.
He's got everything under wraps.
Someone knows until this whole financial
collapse came along and this bernie made
off thing,
came along.
I was like,
oh,
they don't even know.
Nobody even knows.
Nobody knows how this thing works.
No,
it's,
it's a,
it's a belief system that's crazy that
you have to believe that it worked.
I started reading,
I started reading up on it and I
started,
you know,
as I always do,
I read a little bit and then I start
pontificating and then two follow up
questions that in my whole argument
falls on the ground.
But after reading a little bit more,
I've read that book,
the case against the fed.
And uh,
I stopped talking to people about it
because it's like if I really start
informing people and everybody knows
this whole is gonna fucking collapsed.
So I just became part of the line that I
liked,
lIke people going to put your money in
the bank.
it's safe that it's insured up to 200
really and you're going to go with
insurance companies.
The only people that's fucking more
corrupt.
Yeah,
it's insured until it isn't.
The craziest thing is when you go to New
York in times square and you said that
one building that has the national debt
and how it's accumulating and it's just
spinning.
Just add an extra fucking zero to it
recently.
Oh yeah.
No,
they coming around.
They had a,
like,
we hit a point,
the legal amount of debt we're allowed
to have.
So we didn't know what the fuck to do.
So they had a quick meeting and then
they just doubled.
It just doubled.
So now it's not a problem.
No,
it's only halfway there now.
So,
um,
yeah,
do what I gotta admit like this.
There's a lot of terrifying things about
living out here in los angeles,
living in a city that is in a bankrupt
state with the,
you know,
it doesn't really have a water supply.
Technically.
You live in a fucking desert.
The property is like a really overrun
and all that crazy.
A drug cartel shit.
Emmy is essentially a couple of years
rapidly.
It's right down the fucking street
drive.
It's like if you live in in Afghanistan
and the war is two hours away,
he'd be like,
wow,
we're pretty close to the sheer.
You know what I'm saying?
They take a road trip.
You want to go to the war today?
Yeah.
Literally.
Especially when you're in san diego.
Whenever I'm down in san diego,
you're fucking half an hour from 10
walnuts.
Unsettling and those,
those,
you know,
something.
This,
something that I wish there was a
mexican comedian here right now.
I really just thought it was because of
this call will be barcelona one I've
always wondered is why they got so
offended by that sign that has the
running.
Mexicans don't running family across the
street.
Why is that offensive?
We don't want to run over you.
people are embarrassed because they're
embarrassed by the idea that mexicans
have to get into this country that way
and oh,
I get it.
It's embarrassing.
It's not realistic because there's only
three people in the field.
It's embarrassing.
The whole idea about Mexico being that
close,
you know,
it's got to be embarrassing.
There's no other place in the world that
I know of where there's a first world
country connected to a third world
country.
You know what the fuck is this solution?
See If you open the borders and you let
people go everywhere that they.
Like I said,
this is not gonna last,
this,
this standard of living that we have in
America.
It wouldn't be the same if we had open
borders and anybody could just immigrate
to America,
it would get fucked quick.
yeah.
You goTta have the gated community a.
Well that's what the United States is.
It's like a big fucking gated community.
well,
I don't think you should just be able to
walk.
I can.
I like,
we get a lot of shit for that.
I mean,
can I just.
Can you just walk into France some
places you can pretty much go anywhere
you want if you wanted to.
You know what I'm saying?
Legally,
can I just.
Can I just start living in France?
I don't know.
I know I can go there and visit and get
fucking do it.
I could actually.
That's one of my things I really want to
do is I want to,
I would love to become fluent in and be
able to speak french and then go over
there and act as the ignorant american
just to hear the shit.
Yeah,
just act as dumb as I plan my ex eiffel
tower.
Ain't that big mona lisa's sitting there
all expressionless my ex fucking whoop
blonde hair.
My ex just blonde hair girl but could
speak spanish.
So it was great.
She like,
she would have her own fond just going
in,
You know,
listening to people talk about her when
she walked by and stuff.
But she ain't did shit to ship a bust
them,
huh?
Oh,
nonstop.
She would bust them all the time.
Like we'd be waiting in line at el lpo
local and they would say like looking at
chicks tits or something like that.
She'd be like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
But like,
you know,
back in spanish or she was giving me her
phone number.
I don't know if you hit like single de
gado.
No,
I got the rosetta stone.
A spanish speaker one,
you want to learn spanish?
Yeah,
dude,
I got it in christmas.
oh,
eight,
right on the plastic.
Still on it.
It's like an elliptical machine for me.
It's like those fucking mavis baking
learned how to type.
I buy those fucking things every couple
of years old.
They've got learn how type program.
Virtually.
I'm alert type.
I use I type quick,
but I use fucking three fingers.
I use like these two in this one and
I'll go every now and then I'll throw
this motherfucker in the mix,
maybe three fingers on this hand and I
kind of moved to two on this hand so I
don't use the whole burn victim type,
like a fad.
My hand smash with hammers,
but I always say I'm going to eventually
get that fucking mavis bacon.
I'm going to get on it
though you.
You'll be like,
I'm really surprised at some of the shit
that I finally like.
The only thing I ever worked on was
being a comedian because I thought it
was going to solve all my problems.
People are going to see me on stage.
He's funny and every going to stop
fucking with me and everything was gonna
work out and then what ended up
happening is the only thing I was
remotely decent that was being a
comedian.
So I finally learned how to start fixing
shit.
Like what kind of shit did I fix my
toilet and one in New York.
I got a tenant back there and he was
bitching about something.
We got this fucking awful landlord.
He always comes in,
I swear to god with used parts from
other,
other apartments and they never worked.
So I just looked in the back like I was
just picturing how dumb he looks yet he
knows how to do it.
So I just,
I don't know what I did.
I went on youtube and watched a couple
of videos,
a toilet.
It's basic and I just sorta figured shit
out.
Um,
and I listened,
I flushed it,
I looked,
I figured out what the flapper.
It's a fucking $8 flapper and then I got
it.
Now it's like,
fuck,
how does this go in?
And he's just like,
just,
it's almost like when I got better at
computers where I stopped freaking out
and I just was like,
just stop,
take in information,
process it and think that's what I
fucking it.
Second,
I wish I had the time,
the patients and the interest to build
my own car because I would love to get
one of those kits.
Corvette,
who can do that now?
The body's good on fucking toss at 3:50.
I wish they didn't do it with bondo.
It's off the mask.
On the old jeep kits,
you remember the old jeep kits.
You could buy a kit and build your own
army.
Jeep,
remember it was like a thousand bucks or
something like that.
They still have costs.
And you can take a kit car like a noble.
I remember they used to sell the noble
in America,
but you couldn't buy with a powertrain.
You couldn't buy with an engineer to put
your own engine.
You're on powertrain in it.
so it's basically like a do it yourself
fucking car
guy,
uh,
who had a friend in this state I used to
live in.
I'm not going to say where,
but uh,
back in the day that jeep cj seven,
they basically kept the same chassis,
body,
all that shit for like fucking 15 years,
so he had some old piece of shit.
One,
so he did was he went out and he stole a
brand new one and just parked them side
by side in his garage and just took
apart the new one and put all the new so
all the numbers still match whatever the
numbers are supposed to be like on the
frame and all that to everything matched
and he just,
he did like a,
like plastic surgery and he just took
all the new shit that he needed a,
I think he had to keep his engine block
and there was the frame or something
like gearheads would know what he would
have to do with the,
the rest of the stuff.
Then he just took like,
he had like a welt and he was like a
welding thing and he just sort of cut it
into pieces
of remember the greatest scape when they
would just drive the dirt on the bottom.
Yeah.
We just sort of dumped shit here or
there.
If you just have a piece of a frame,
they're not going to give a fuck or you
know,
I don't even know what it is.
How do you prove it?
Yeah,
I mean,
yeah,
I mean I didn't really.
I mean I don't have the mechanical know
how to say exactly what he did,
but I.
But I said what did he do with the extra
shit?
And it was basically yet he cut it down
into smaller pieces.
You can't fucking build a car today.
Like you can't build a new 2011 shelby
mustang convertible.
You can't build it now with no.
But when you can do and there's so much
shit going on.
It's like,
it's so complicated.
You know,
it's not like the old days,
you know,
if you,
if you in the old days,
if you're fucking engine blew,
you could replace your engine,
you know,
all you need is like a crane and a buddy
knew what the fuck he was doing and you
know,
but it was also much more like my first
card I had,
I had a ford ranger and I actually
learned if I wanted to go,
I just didn't have the balls to do it
because I didn't have a friend who could
fix the problem,
you know what I mean?
So I had to keep it very light.
I was like a hygienist,
but like working on fucking car,
I,
you learned,
you know,
changing the oil is the first thing.
Then You learn how to change the belts,
then you start doing the spark plugs and
you get the timing light.
And I got right to the point where I was
going to start fucking with the,
I dunno what trying to do like the
pistons and shit and maybe I'll,
uh,
I'll try to get some more horsepower in
this.
And I was just like,
phil,
it's a fucking ford ranger,
two wheel drive.
what are you at?
I'm happy.
Just be happy that it says that is
running a change once.
And I dumped it into the sewer and
dumped it into one of those.
That was legal.
I didn't even think I was 17 years old.
I was.
And,
and as I'm dumping in,
this guy walks by,
he goes,
yeah,
that's a good place for that.
I thought,
yeah,
that's a good place.
And I thought about like,
oh,
he's making fun of me.
Oh my god,
I'm a douche bag.
God,
why did I think it was okay to pour the
oil and it's fucking drink.
And then I thought that fucks with me
today.
Really still still.
I think about it sometimes I think about
sometimes that I poured oil into the
drain,
like a retard and that this guy came by
and go,
yeah,
that's a good place with that.
And then I was so dumb.
I was like,
yeah,
it is a good place for it.
Right?
It fucks with you because you're into
the environment or because he made you
look stupid because I was a retard,
not because it made me look stupid.
I was stupid.
He probably thinks the same thing like
that asshole.
I can't probably still.
It's probably dead.
That'll fuck.
There's a long time ago you were
uninformed because you're uninformed.
He becomes an old facility and old.
Fuck you.
You piece of shit makes it funnier.
You know?
There's so many weird things like that.
That gentleman,
he's probably passed away.
There's so many weird things like that
that you're not allowed to dispose of
like that to monitor water.
Man.
It gets into the ocean,
but the crazy thing is that the oil
put in is nothing compared to what's on
the fucking road every day.
I mean,
everybody's leaking oil.
You're driving up and down the street at
range,
goes in the gutter,
right?
Yo shout,
justify it.
any way you have to justify it.
I told you I'm ashamed to this day.
One time I was in,
I was fishing and dump it in the woods
really has taken because I didn't.
I didn't smell as bad as that river.
I didn't know.
I didn't know that you weren't supposed
to do that.
And then.
But then I figured out they had this
place down the street near the fire
department.
They had this big giant thing that you
just,
you just dumped your oil and right back
in the day when there wasn't a computer
chips and it was easy.
I was in the,
uh,
I was in the charles river fishing once
and it was right across the street from
my house where I lived in boston and I
saw this bubbling in the water and I
couldn't figure out what the fuck it
was.
I was looking,
I was like,
something's like bubbling,
like water's coming up.
It's kind of crazy.
And then I saw a rubber and then I
realized that what I was looking at with
shit,
some of it was shed broken sewer pipe
that was pouring directly into the
river.
So every time people flush their toilet
shit and piss and rubbers and tampons,
which is floating in this,
in this fucking river,
disgust and finished medicine.
Oh,
it was so nasty.
And I went for a little bit further
down.
There was a waterfall at the bottom of
the waterfall that was foam.
It was so much chemicals in the water
that had made like a thick,
white and yellow foam at the bottom of
the water.
Yep.
There you go.
That's,
that's.
You know what's worse is like a baby
diapers in parking.
Lots of like target.
The other day was that there were just
these little squares where they like
change the diaper and they're laying on
the ground stuff.
I got out and stepped right on it.
It was just like.
It's just like everywhere.
I see it all the time now.
The bourbon landmine,
I apologize for that.
That's a big thing to do.
I guess you don't want to keep it in
your car when you drive home.
My car always has diapers in it.
My wife takes these diapers,
wraps him up and he's little bombs and
leaves them there.
And then I hop in my car,
lyn shift funds,
a little diaper bombs everywhere,
little piss bombs.
They're everywhere.
They're all fucking house.
That newborn smell,
it's
not that bad.
My two year old has some pretty stinky
poops,
but you know at this point the kids
probably going to like fucking
mcdonald's.
No starting to screw up their colon
itam.
I don't serve them shitty food.
Fuck that.
She gets.
She gets fries and stuff occasionally in
ice cream occasionally,
but for the most part she eats healthy
food.
If you get them into eating shitty food
or get make shitty food,
a big deal,
make it exciting.
You know,
make it something special.
Now that's why mcdonald's is a fucking
playground.
He dragged my mcdonald's.
She's sees these bright colors and tubes
and slides and shit and they just want
to go in there.
But the foods,
if I ever have kids,
I'm gonna.
Feed him shit food,
make them fat so I can feel it can be,
feel better about myself.
You know.
See the first person I've ever seen feed
their kid octopus.
I was like,
whoa,
octopus.
That's ridiculous.
Enjoys it.
She asked for octopus and people like
your fucking kids asking for octopus.
I can't.
That's too fishy.
Too chewy.
Do I ever eat octopus sushi?
Yeah,
I've,
I've Tried to mess.
Delicious.
Yeah,
I love it now.
That's,
that's when like the,
the hardcore japanese guys given you the
fucking heads up.
like you know what you're doing.
Like the closer it is,
that means you're really into nasty
shit.
I,
that's my other favorite food.
I'm the classic american sushi.
I'm like,
yeah,
let me get a yellow tail hand roll.
Spicy California roll.
Yeah,
telling the fish tuna roll.
I keep it real.
Put salmon,
salmon,
avocado.
I keep it really a me too.
That's even like eel eel roll I liked
but I just kinda,
that's just something to like tonight is
standard.
I don't have any sort of guilt when I
eat that even though they're dying off.
But elijah just seems like an
unnecessary one to,
to eat really eel sauce.
I don't like it
ill because of the sauce.
I only like sushi that you don't need
sauce for like look yellow tail tuna,
that kind of shit.
How,
how bad are the tuna going extinct?
Is that like a big deal?
I don't know.
Everything's going extinct because
there's too many fucking people and we
keep.
The problem is is they make too much
money off of us like we're not like
we're not.
People were these things they make money
off of so they need as much of us around
against that.
All,
all,
all the animals are going to come back.
When the robots,
when the robots take over,
it'd be like,
I am legend.
Deer running through the streets of
manhattan.
That kind of shit.
I don't think it'd be that bad debt
because they'll keep manhattan,
but it'll definitely be like in jersey,
jersey,
we'll all grow over.
I wenT to Colorado.
People are useless.
I went to Colorado and I was living
there for four months and when I came
back a deer had decided to make my
backyard home in la,
this right out here,
and every day this deer would be
wandering through my yard,
chewing grass,
and they just decided to.
Since nobody was here,
there's no noise.
They just started moving in.
Interesting.
Soon as I moved back in,
she stopped coming around,
but she could literally jump that fence
six feet high and it's fucking a wrought
iron.
She'd jump right?
Oh yeah,
they got it.
It's got to be eight feet.
I got a buddy of mine has a,
has a problem with that,
so he's got this eight foot my cheek.
You're really not that naval.
He'd say,
no dude,
I got a kitten and the name at the deer
come in.
Yeah,
they really do.
They hop right over six foot fence.
It's incredible to watch it.
So I just fly through the air,
but they were moving in and they were
ready to take over.
You goT a gun range out here?
Uh,
I got a fake pig that I shoot arrows
into.
Can we do that after the podcast?
So you teach me how to do that shit once
you down.
I'm learning how to.
A couple of things.
I'm learning how to pick a lock on.
Yeah,
I'm going to be.
Then when those urban survivor guys,
whenever you'd like a thousand degrees
in this room really is.
Let me just turn on the.
I just talked to these people.
I turned the ac.
I'm learning how to pick a lock on
youtube.
I'm trying to learn how to hot wire a
car.
Youtube is great for that shit.
Yeah,
you can.
Fuck dude.
I've taught myself how to play guitar,
play drums.
I've watched people get knocked out,
get kicked in the balls,
hide a camera into the toilet paper roll
thing and cited that in the bathroom.
I found out how to do that.
Oh really?
Yeah.
You can become a real fucking creep up
on youtube and all that.
That's what I love about the internet.
You really can just become the person
that you.
If you feel like you know,
I want to be a better read.
You can go to wikipedia and see what
morons think about the subject that you
want to learn about or if you want to
add a little creepy shit to your,
to your,
uh,
to your personality,
you can do that.
I want to learn how to pick a fucking
luck just so I can do it.
Yeah,
because I.
Because I only know the credit card
technique where you slide it in and that
never works,
you know?
Were you surprised that they was
showing?
I was watching somebody like,
firstly you have to know like how a lock
works,
like what it is in there and this person
is really,
you know,
like the little clip on thing from the
pen.
They'd somehow jam that in there and
then take like a hairpin.
I'm so full of shit I didn't,
haven't learned.
I watched somebody do it and I want to
try it.
That's basically it.
But the overhead is I have to buy a lock
so I haven't quite committed to it.
You know what?
I'm going to buy the lock and it's going
to sit right on top of my fucking learn
how to speak spanish.
I figure if I'm going into a log,
I might as well took the door and a
martial art training
bag.
It's not going to move or hit you back.
It's not hard to kick a door.
Right?
Those are easy.
That's why it's funny when you see a guy
like on those fucking,
those uh,
videos of cops breaking the doors and
the guy looked,
especially the old school ones from the
sixties.
You guys kicking the door over and over
again to kick it,
to break doors or all doors are raising
come.
He's not able to do it because he's a
faggot.
well,
there you go.
I never understood why they own window.
There is something about.
Yeah,
literally he likes sex with the same.
Where's my water?
Yours.
This is empty.
I to take a chance.
There's one last time.
Mine was right there.
You don't want to take a chance.
You're the one who busted out the fake
asshole admitted into this podcast.
Well,
I don't mean when I say faggot,
it was in a gay man.
You mean pussy?
Yeah.
That's one of my words.
I will not give up no matter how much
people give me shit about know now.
Louis ck,
he's got that big chunk on it.
I have a problem with that.
That word to me is not a gay slur.
You know what really drives me crazy
when they're saying you can't say gay,
but you can't say that's gay,
like it's offensive or insensitive.
Well,
didn't always mean joyful and beginning.
It made you know,
like,
have a
gay happy gay nineties,
the 18 nineties and change.
There'll be sexual and why can't they
accept that?
It also means lame because a certain
groups own words.
What if you spell it g h e y,
gaze zone,
gay jewish people own holocaust,
you know,
that whole thing.
Jim jefferies.
Dope.
Were you on the hand wiping after the
show?
Was it,
were you on the show when jeffries was
talking about is uh,
oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Ridiculous.
Is that he wanted a jim jefferies,
hilarious comedian.
One of the name is a dvd alcoholic cost
the up and apparently the defendant,
a bunch of jewish people.
They got super upset.
I think it offended the,
the ones who are in the group.
I think generally speaking,
most people don't give a shit.
I don't know about that.
I would say that a lot of people who are
jewish probably have a problem with
that.
People are very,
very sensitive to that.
Now they don't want you to cracking
jokes on something that fucked up their
whole,
you know.
Well,
he explained it and he didn't even need
to explain it.
I get it.
I didn't think he was making fun of
jewish people.
He was saying like,
he's drinking so much that he's a
holocaust having a holocaust of alcohol.
You can't own a word.
I mean it just calling something a whoa.
Look,
what would they need another word for
what happened to the jews in nazi
Germany?
I mean,
it's a horrible,
horrible thing and it is a holocaust,
but it's not the only holocaust.
You can't own that word now.
You can't treat it like the Ohio state
university.
It's a tricky one.
The holocaust,
like it's trademarked.
It's a word to describe anything that's
atrocious.
Anything that's horrible.
I mean,
that's really what it is.
It's a,
it's a word to describe.
Usually.
I've never looked it up.
I don't know what.
let's look up the official term of
holocaust.
Brian,
tell us what it is.
I look up a and then look up the law.
I mean,
look,
it was clear,
it's not that he's making light of this
horrible situation that has happened.
it was a play on words,
but then he did make light.
Then he fucked up and said they should
get over it.
It was his fucking 60 years ago.
Fucking get over it.
I thought what the accent,
he'd get away with it because it sounded
cheeky.
Australia is the shit.
Have you ever done comedy over there?
Uh,
yeah,
I did,
but it was a typical thing where it was
like,
they was a three day thing where they
flew over for one day.
They gave you a day to get fucking used
to it.
Uh,
and then,
then you did the gig and then they flew
you back.
I stuck around for a couple days ago.
that's kind of how I was in sydney.
I was only in sydney for a couple of
days,
but I did a gig up there.
I wanted to see all those fucking snakes
over there.
We saw kangaroos,
kangaroos at kill people all the time.
There's these big giant fucking
kangaroos called gray kangaroos and they
tell you if you run into gray kangaroos,
you better leave.
Just get the fuck away from there.
Super aggressive and they're really big.
They're like the fucking 318 and the
relation and the kick you in the stomach
and fucking glory.
You bugs bunny.
They leaned back in the tail.
I do that,
but they do glean back in the tail and
attack you,
but they have claws,
man.
They'll rip your fucking stomach apart.
They'll fuck you up when they get
inside.
I haven't watched enough ufc.
that fucking elbow.
You've got to claim the most important
thing.
Can you get that clinch?
You got no space between you and take
the kangaroo to the ground.
They're there.
They've got a great standup.
Then I bounced right back to their feet,
bro.
Don't even try.
They're fucking fucking arms are too
small.
The grapple.
If you go to the under hooks ups,
but you've got to go randy coture star.
We juSt press them up against a tree and
work them over with.
Nice.
Hey,
just breaking balls.
Work on animals.
Racking balls.
Yeah,
like if you rack a dog's balls,
do they go at all or are we the only
ones?
I think it hurts them,
but I think when an animal gets into
that state where they're attacking,
trying to kill you,
they don't think about painting the way
people do.
You know,
I,
I've seen dogs fight with each other and
they're,
they're wagging their tail like happy.
Meanwhile they're ripping each other's
faces apart,
especially pitbulls pitbulls.
They don't,
they don't seem to experience any pain.
When they fight,
they seem to just just do it and then
think about the pain later,
like they block it out somehow because I
would not count on kicking a dog and the
balls.
If a dog is attacking you,
your best move is to choke it
unconscious.
I wonder if there's videos of monkeys
getting racked.
Know monkeys.
I'm sure it would suck.
They know her.
They know it sucks because when they
attack people and chimps attack people
that go for your balls,
that's one of the number one things.
So do they try to eat your genitalia
that a rip your balls off and then
usually twist your foot off to take your
fingers off the bite.
People's fingers off.
They go for your balls to try to blind
you.
They try to take away everything that
makes you human.
All your valuable assets,
your ability to control things,
your ability to use your dick.
I fucked up.
I hate monkeys.
Really?
I just some a bottom.
I don't like chimps or scariest.
I don't mind chimps.
I don't mind gorillas,
but those little fucking throwing shit
at you.
Spider monkeys.
I jusT don't fucking lie.
I think it's from Indiana jones because
that monkey was a dick and ever since
some aggregated small month dixon organ
grinder guy from back when I was a kid
down in faneuil hall,
they would always.
Granted they've had to wear that stupid
bellboy outfit so they probably weren't
in a good mood,
but they will always creepy.
Yeah.
I grew up with a monkey now,
not my monkey monkey by my grandmother's
monkey.
You're criminal.
Had a monkey,
a grandmother and a monkey named chichi.
Chichi lived in the attic.
And you couldn't ever have chichi around
people because she,
she would bite you,
cheat,
you would chew gum,
she would give her gum and he would
unwrap the gum it in his mouth,
but he only liked my grandmother,
didn't trust anybody else.
And if anybody got near him,
cheat you would attack you.
But when I was in Costa Rica,
I had a monkey.
It was fucking crazy.
Monkey jumped on my back.
It was like the monkey that they had in
the area.
Okay.
And the compound where I was staying,
jumped on my back,
hooked it's tail around my neck.
And so now it's hanging.
It's inverted,
hanging upside down.
It went right in my pocket,
took my hotel keys and then went up the
tree in like two seconds.
And I'm only standing there like,
did that just fucking happen?
He's serious.
This is now sitting there.
And I got some fucking,
I don't know,
some sort of costa rican kiwi trying to
get this fucking monkey come down.
I forget it.
I remember I,
I fucking,
my human brain out did is a monkey
brain.
And I got it back and I did a quick
switcheroo and I ran because it was on a
chain and I was able to just get away.
And the thing thing was so pissed that I
was running where to go.
It just fucking screamed at me.
Pissed.
I was mad,
man.
I was like,
yeah,
there you go.
You fucker.
Well that's what happens in India.
They steal things from people and then
they want you to give them food back.
You give them food and they give you
whatever,
you know,
whenever they took from you.
And then do they kill la?
Kill animals.
Killed people.
Oh,
they're in their house.
The mayor of one of the towns in India.
He got killed by monkeys recently.
Like within the last couple of years.
They fucking swarmed his ass.
Just jack them.
What's the monkeYs with big,
puffy?
It's like the pit on India.
The bumpy problems.
Like the ones that have is it rang tang
has the weird crazy things.
Crazy.
How about baboons?
It was like a half a dog.
Half of a monkey.
Yeah.
That's a weird animal.
Baboons eat babies too,
man.
So to chimps,
chimps eat babies.
If you,
if you leave babies around and chimps
eat them,
eat them.
Yeah.
They're still not worse than bankers.
Have you ever seen the video,
the chimp eating the monkey?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Then finally realizing that they do that
and they also,
they sewed all talk shit after they do
it,
they feel like stopped beating their
chest.
They're very already a ruthless
motherfuckers.
I thought for the longest time it was a
rang of tang.
Like the orange drink.
No,
it's.
Well that's not really neanderthals
neanderthal,
you know,
it's named after a part and part of
France.
That's where they found the first
skeletons.
did they been selling sand recently?
That people are.
Most people or a good percentage of
people have neanderthal genetics in them
and that we,
uh,
somehow or another absorb them.
I do look at my forehead.
I got to hook a frankenstein forehead.
Dude.
My eyebrows like,
look at that.
That ultimate doom.
I tell me I don't have the same brown.
That's true.
Is that fucking thing is not that I want
to show you my dentist.
My dentist is so freaky.
I will drive you over to his office just
to say hi,
just so you could see his head really is
fucking for his dentist,
man.
It's,
it sticks out like this far,
like no bullshit.
It doesn't even look real.
It looks like he's wearing a chin up
bar.
Like you put a clean on plate from star
wars.
The next generation will put it on his
head.
I mean,
it really looks like that.
He's just got this,
these deeps his eyes.
No bullshit or like that.
Deep into his head.
My dentist is kind of crazy.
My dentist is like that.
What's that movie?
Uh,
people under the stairs or whatever.
Where danny,
what's I should say this in case my
dentist is listening.
He's a great guy.
Look,
I'm not fucking perfect either.
I look like a champ.
I don't know what the best looking guy
in the world who liked.
Those guys are all depressed and he's a
very nice guy.
we already hung up.
Very nice guy,
but he's got a big crazy for him.
That's just a fact.
I didn't name any day.
You know what's funny about that shit
with that big forehead and went up that
affects that light that they have on
their head.
If it's too far and it just shines on
the back of your head.
He's getting adjusted to far and he's
got a pointed straight down.
Some people even use that or am I
thinking of minors?
I think dennis probably use that shit
to.
And the digging deep in mouth.
It should,
right?
yeah,
that sounds oppressive.
Rough job.
My dentist hypnotizes me.
There's a part where they checked for
cancer.
I don't know if you're a dentist.
Do that where they go.
Okay,
so this is where you're so and so gland
dentists.
Dentists stick his fingers in your
mouth.
No,
no,
but then you wake up and you're like,
what happened?
Did you ever see that guy?
oh,
that would feel girls put them under and
they busted him.
He,
they busted us.
And what I loved about that guys,
you could tell he never got arrested for
anything in his life and he just,
he just like,
he just,
you saw it and his whole body,
he was just like,
okay,
like the girl was under,
right?
And she,
she kept waking up feeling like her bra
wasn't right the way it should've been.
So they basically get her to go in there
again to go under and they drilled in
from like the cvs next door or some
shit.
and they got this camera.
So he starts fucking second.
He starts being certainly seem.
You seem like,
yeah,
I'm going,
I have a testing,
has all this type of shit.
And then immediately all these swat guys
coming in,
it goes literally from that to.
And my life's over and he just fucking
shoulders slumped dragged out.
Can you imagine what happened to that
guy in prison?
You're going in as a fucking sex
offender.
Dentist who probably hasn't had a height
since the third grade.
No gang affiliation.
Who would have to join one who would
take him?
You gotta.
You gotta be somebody bits the first
night you got to stock some cock right
away.
You gotta put on a dress.
Whooo.
You think of some guys in prison like,
what the fuck is gonna happen?
Like bernie madoff.
What's what's going on with that guy in
prison?
they must be beating the fuck on it on
it's white collar that probably guys
guys will get.
Now he's probably holding courT.
Is he in a white collar prison?
He said,
absolutely.
he probably can get fresca spite.
The fact that his felonies were so
egregious that because they're not
violent,
they don't give a shit so and so and he
nonviolent offenses.
They put them with other nonviolent
people.
I don't know how it works,
dude.
I just know if you're rich,
you don't go to real jail.
But he actually fucked.
The problem was was not how much money
he took was I think who we took it from
and they had as much influence if not
more as he did.
So he actually got life in prison.
That unusual.
I just pulled that on my ass.
I have no idea what fucking.
I think it's unusual that he got life in
prison.
I mean,
what he did was fucking $50,
million dollars.
That's,
you got to put them In jail for life.
There's no way he's going to pay that
back.
I mean,
what would be.
Did you see that thing in,
in uh,
in rolling stone that this month,
matt [inaudible] article that it was the
one about,
uh,
those kids that have the biggest
internet cyberspace crime ever?
Yeah.
I haven't read that yet.
oh,
he got to read.
That shit will make you super paranoid
about where you use your credit card.
These guys would sit outside the mall.
This was,
this was their,
uh,
their,
their hacky way.
They first did it would sit there in a
car with like a fucking eight foot to
antenna and they somehow tap in to
whatever that shit in the fucking air is
that computer shit.
The satellite thing went back to that.
And as you use the credit cards,
they somehow they would break into the
system or something.
I don't want to,
I can't even explain it to fucking dumb,
but it's even,
even for a guy like me,
it was fascinating.
So there was some sort of a wireless
transmission of your car,
your credit card,
you in there,
right?
Buying a thermal.
okay.
Alright.
And you swipe your card and as they're
putting it into the system or as you
swipe it somehow that tapped into this
shit through the fucking air.
It's literally like magic,
like all those years of people pulling
out rabbits out of hats and it was all
bullshit.
These guys,
I don't know how the fuck they were
doing it.
So they would do that and then they were
like,
oh,
this is bullshit.
It's too,
it's too risky.
Um,
they somehow then they took it to the
next level and they got into the main
database database.
Thank you.
I needed a word.
I'll go with that.
The main database of all the macy's or
whatever,
and people's critical.
yeah,
they,
yeah.
They got like,
like,
I don't know,
I'm going to,
what number am I?
Seven say 50 million credit cards.
Banks are totally corrupt.
You think that the banks would hack into
people's shit on purpose,
like hired people to hack into people's
shit?
Well,
this is what I think about.
Don't.
I don't think I,
I,
this is what I don't like is it's not my
money.
It's their money and they give it to me
in my job is to get in debt with it and
if I don't then they just fucking take
it for me.
That's basically what happens.
Right?
But I mean the hackers,
I mean tanked.
Do you think that,
you know how like the cia's always been
accused of selling drugs and the,
the,
the argument for it is the bad guys are
going to sell drugs no matter what you
do.
The cia takes that money and use it for
covert operation to protect americans,
blah,
blah.
The cia's always sold drugs and that's
just the way it is.
Do you think that the bankers would get
involved in hacker activity just because
they figured,
look,
someone's going to do this,
we're going to do this
at this point.
It might be in another.
They just look at everything as revenue
streams.
Yeah,
I don't think that they look at shit,
well not we worked because they will be
self,
they will be sabotaging themselves,
but I,
I,
this is my questions like,
um,
I'm always looking at these,
but I don't think bank,
I really don't think bankers are above
stealing.
Now,
of course
these hacker situations and I go,
okay,
you hear about this fucking russian
teenager made $50,000,000
in a year,
you know,
in his basement and then he started an
empire,
blah,
blah blah.
And he was just a hacker.
Well,
if I'm reading about this,
there's got to be some people that are
rich and powerful and recognize that $50
million some real money and if this
goofball kid in his basement is making
that kind of money,
is there a way they can do that?
And what I mean,
is there any of this shit they have to
hack into their own system.
I Think that they do it.
They,
they steal from the uh,
um,
the people who put money on us,
the customers,
they still through like fees,
right?
Well,
they definitely do that too.
I didn't get the gun a risk what they
have for doing hacker shit.
You know what I mean?
like if this guy is super rich,
he's not going to risk everything as
America,
but I've been a button.
Some other countries are pulling some
shit off.
There's something about that shit
though,
where I find that that type of shit is
so fascinating where you know,
you learn how to pick a lock.
The bullshit that I'm doing is no big
deal,
but those guys who can actually,
you know,
hack their way.
I'll tell you what's even more
interesting is that you'd be going to
youtube.
There's ways to show you how to get
those like things that you put on atm at
the gas pump and there's videos showing
how to do it,
like how and where to buy them,
where it's like this thing that fits
over the credit card slot at your gas
pump and there's like a little camera
that you tape into the corner.
So wheN you're using outside right now,
that's why you never use your fucking
atm because that's your money.
They get their shit,
they get your money,
they get to be a fucking credit card
that's citibank's money,
so then they'll call you up and be like,
you know,
did you buy a tank top and Kansas city
now?
I did not ever get that.
You have to be on the road so much.
I used to be on the road,
like they would constantly be shutting
my credit card off and not realizing
that I was a comedian.
They'd be lIke,
did you get a lap dance and toronto?
Yes.
I did get chicken wings days later in st
louis.
Yes.
I know.
They finally like,
what are you do?
I'm a comedian.
I'm on a college tour.
yeah,
you should always usually never do debit
either.
You should always do credit card.
You know where they are always trying to
triCk you into like,
that's what I'm saying.
Put in your pin and you're like,
no,
I'm not putting my pants on as a credit
card.
Don't ever do that.
Because then it also protects her ship
for 30 days to,
yeah,
fuck that,
fuck all that.
Do it.
And they're trying to make it.
They're gonna make a cashless,
cashless the shit cash isn't going to go
Back to work.
One piece of gold,
one donkey.
That's what we got to go fight a piece
of it off to get some potatoes.
Something you got to get something for
something.
Your money has to represent something.
The problem is our monday doesn't
actually represent anything.
It's just an idea.
It's just confidence.
We have confidence at $100 is worth
$100,
but it doesn't represent $100.
Gold.
It's just keep that confidence.
I'm alright with it
dude.
I like your hall of fame of fucking keys
you have in there.
That's hilarious.
I'm looking into joseph's walk in closet
right now.
Most people have like fucking jerseys
from sports.
They never played.
That says dexter trophies.
Yeah.
He still has like dried blood from some
kid.
He fucking hammer fisted back in is
revered days.
My taekwondo middles on the door knob.
That's all shit from the eighties.
So that was one of my favorite from my
other life.
Yeah,
that's one of my favorite fucking
responses.
I was.
I was on his.
Hey,
your website way back in the day and
some kid was given him shit,
so joe,
you know,
just blast some whatever.
You're just a fucking loser.
And then he Writes,
oh,
what do you mean I'm a fucking loser?
He goes,
I'm only 20 years old,
but blah,
blah blah.
What were you doing at 20?
And shows like a,
I was a national champion taekwondo.
Fucking loser per like one of the few
guys who was actually a success before
they got into this shit.
Well,
I was,
but I definitely wasn't a financial
success.
That's why you weren't doing a taekwondo
toi was teaching.
I was teaching at boston university.
I was teaching at bu when I was 19.
I taught at boston university.
That's horrible.
That's way bubble.
Most people.
Well,
I was a bang and half the kids in your
class if I fucked a few of them.
Wonderful.
She was so
hot and uh,
she was just,
I don't want to say her name,
but she was just really hot latina.
Check kelly.
Chris.
Then I saw her again like three years
ago and she wasn't the type of girl to
work out,
so it was just type of girl that,
you know,
when she was young,
she was 19 when I was 19.
She just getting by on her looks,
but now she's like 41 and she doesn't
exercise and it was so sad.
She's probably sad to see me too.
I was a fucking handsome looking fellow,
but it's broken down man.
Joe coming in at 19 to teach the class.
He probably did that.
John claude van damme.
Fucking split between two desks and that
was,
that ran through the whole class from
that year,
from the,
from 15 till I was 21.
I was literally.
All I did was fight.
All I did was train and fight.
That's all I did.
I didn't have any social life.
I had a girlfriend here and there.
They would always get sick of me and
break up with me and whatever,
but all I did was train and fight.
I didn't party.
I didn't drink.
Very rarely did I drink and I smoke pot
twice from like 15 to 21.
That's all I did was fine.
He was completely out of my head and I
went from that to two from from going to
talk window straight into going to
comedy,
kickboxing.
I had a few three kickboxing fights and
then I went right into comedy because I
knew I was going nowhere.
So there's no money in it.
What's your opening like standup?
Was it about.
No,
no,
no.
I never talked to that really intense.
Was like,
hello,
this is my comedy.
I tried to do it.
You got to talk about your life now.
Never talked about that.
There's no,
no one wants to take some fucking guys a
martial arts champion.
Right.
That's the thing,
because he was actually good at it like
this,
that you've got to be,
have like low self esteem.
You could say,
you know,
if you can say,
ah,
I find a taekwondo tournament once and I
fought on friday and when I finally woke
up on tuesday,
you know,
after some.
So not doing comedy.
I like,
you can't
say that.
Oh,
so I fucking kicked this dude in the
head and knocked him into a coma.
That's not funny.
No,
but when I,
when I started out though,
there was like,
you know,
because all those,
all those headliners didn't leave.
We will like kind of fucked.
He ended up headlining.
We were looking at the only guys who
kind of busted through was you and
Anthony Clark with the two guys at the
time who would actually somehow gotten
past the old boy network.
Yeah.
Well they left,
you know,
anthony was one of the uh,
nick depaulo left too.
They just left,
you know,
you had to leave.
You can't stay in boston.
It was so intoxicating because you can
make a living.
You could be in boston in the unit if
you were a nobody,
you know,
you're still,
you could grind out 500 bucks a week.
You know,
you do here.
Do here.
As long as you're willing to drive and
travel.
If you had $500 cash a week,
you could pay for your bills.
You could eat.
But if you want to try to go on the
road,
man,
good fucking luck.
No tv credits.
No nothing.
Just some guy from boston.
How much are they going to pay you?
But you're fucking gas.
Your air is going to eat up all your
profits.
It's fucking hard.
What are you,
uh,
what do you think now?
because I just went back to boston.
Have you been back there lately?
Yeah.
Yeah?
It's sad.
It's nothing going on there now.
What is the fucking,
the comedy connection?
A theater now,
you know,
it's that big.
Wilbur theater comedy can actually just
be 150 seats that bad as little room.
And now it's,
you know.
No.
But they,
they reopened that right up the street.
The old charles street playhouse.
What's it now?
What's another comedy club called?
I can't remember this one.
Small one in faneuil hall called
motley's.
I did that.
That tim mackenzie's place.
I can't remember what I did.
I ran through all of them.
There was 80,
there was like eight.
And I was like an 85 seater.
I did dick dority's comedy fault.
What I put together,
my basically polished up my first five
minutes of material ever,
so I always go down there.
The vault,
dude,
I fucking love that place and this the
thing hasn't changed at all.
Like I remember when that place started.
This I'll fucking old.
I am now and now it's just celebrated to
mackenzie.
I'm sorry if he's listening to american.
I think it started in [inaudible] 93.
Yeah,
that was a.
it was a year and a son.
No,
no,
no.
The fault.
Tardies.
Comedy vault.
So something.
That shit was around in the eighties,
right?
Because in 88 when I was around the deq
dirty comedy vault was around victoria
is remington's?
Yeah.
That fucking bank.
It's like a bank.
Wow.
It's a fault.
I thought.
I thought spike tobin was the first guy
who opened that shit up.
Might have reopened it.
Might've reopened it.
Okay.
So it might've went under and they
brought it back.
But dick daugherty's comedy vault was a
stapled back when I was living there and
I moved out of boston like 92.
Yeah.
You were gone before I wrote when I
started.
You were already gone?
Um,
yeah.
Where the fuck was I working at?
I think I was.
First time I saw I saw you with the cow
loon.
Oh,
that place.
That was a good place.
Yeah.
And comedy still chinese food and is a
weird combination of exist in boston.
Like the biggest,
the most famous historical comedy club
in boston was the ding ho,
so chinese restaurant that they had
comedy out of and now the only place
that exists that place had a rick
jenkins runs.
He runs a place in cambridge.
Yeah.
And that's the uh,
that's another,
the chinese restaurants restaurant.
His restaurant and upstate you comedy
labs and what they call it?
Yeah.
Remember the,
uh,
the,
the cooler.
Cool.
And then the other places might.
Clark's plays giggles and saugus.
Yeah.
You know,
but there's more work in boston or the
least.
There was like just little road gigs to
an hour drive here.
Our drive there.
More of those in that area than anywhere
else in the country.
No.
When I would talk to guys from like
other places and then I'm like,
where's your road gigs?
Or where do you go for road gigs?
Oh,
you know,
sometimes I do Ohio sometimes.
Like what do you get?
No,
don't you have gigs around here?
Like no one could make a living around
there.
Yeah.
But there's no nobody,
nobody would start like,
I don't know what it is that people
would just start running,
don't have bob marley out of Maine.
He came down like a fully formed fucking
headline or just because he had like 25
rooms going up in Maine.
Like he started basically it was like
mcdonald's.
You have,
you started with like comedies,
isa telling me when he was living up
there and it was getting so big.
He actually ended up leaving because he
almost became,
I think like a kind of almost like a
club owner at that point.
He could have done it.
But um,
he basically started the comedy scene up
there because before that all they had
was like the connection.
But like portland.
Yeah.
And he started like he had at any given
time,
I used to do gigs in bangor and bob
would do like guest bots and shit when
he Was first starting out.
Bobby,
I don't know if you know how famous he
is in Maine,
do you?
No,
no,
no.
I,
yeah,
he's like,
if you don't know who bob marley is.
Very funny guy,
very nice guy.
I've known Him for 20 plus years,
always been just a great guy.
But when he first started out,
you know,
there was like,
this is like probably he probably
started on 89 or 90.
There's no one known from being from
Maine.
There's no like one main comic that
stands up.
But bob marley in anywhere else in the
country is like,
people might have heard of them.
You might have heard them on xm radio,
you might have seen him on comedy
central or something in Maine.
That mother fucker is huge.
Oh yeah.
There's probably no comparison.
It's like laziness or gabriel iglesias
and in la is giant.
Gabriel iglesias does shows in la.
Well,
he'll do like five shows on a monday
night,
like something fucking nutty and sell
out everyone like days and days in
advance.
That's how he is.
Nobody else was like.
Yeah,
no.
He used to go.
I remember he was telling me he would
basically be an la auditioning and then
every year right as the holidays came
around,
he would make like 10 times what I made
on the road in that month.
Yeah.
Just to,
should be talking about is money.
But yeah,
he would just go up there and do parties
and then he do the new year's thing and
this one we be like,
he would do like a,
like a $1,500,
2000 seater and to be doing like adding
shows and
yeah,
doing all this main material,
you know,
so much main.
Like I was listening to them on the
radio the other day was on xm radio is
doing all these main jokes and it was
doing them in Maine.
They were going crazy.
They were
no.
And the he also,
dude,
he has like a box set that so many
albums this dude is put out.
He's put out like 16 albums,
14 elvis fucking unbelievable.
Incredible.
The amount hours,
14 hours of fucking material.
Have you ever heard of anybody say done
that?
Have you ever heard of anybody else?
You just nailed it in one area like
that?
No,
there's.
There's a couple of Who's like that
though?
Not like that,
but it wasn't there a.
They would always hear those guys when
you be down south.
Killer bees.
Remember her killer bees guys and then
there was a.
There was one or two other guys who
south of the mason dixon line would
just.
Absolutely.
If you just put their name up,
there was a few of those thousand
tickets,
a few of those guys,
but I don't think there's any one guy
that's got the state nailed like bob
marley does and he created it.
Yeah,
but it's a state that's proud to be that
state too.
That's a part of the whole key to it.
He's actually from Maine and the people
in Maine are proud to be from Maine.
Yeah.
It's like somebody is getting an idea.
So there's a comedian right now in like
South Dakota trying to put it to.
You're like,
dude,
I could run this fucking town,
state,
whatever the hell I'm trying to say.
Does anybody give a fuck about being
from South Dakota though?
THe thing about being right there,
that's who gave a fuck about being from
maIne.
A lot of main people.
You ever talk shit about me.
People in South Dakota,
they give a fuck about being there.
Not as much as Maine.
I was in North Dakota and they will.
All right with fargo came.
I was like,
we don't talk like that.
That's fucking bullshit.
And whoa.
It's like,
oh,
you think we talked like cliff clavin on
cheers.
We don't.
A lot of us do kind of boston now.
He fucked that accident.
He would go away.
Their ego a,
their nami.
It's norm.
Yeah.
Everything was packed.
The car.
So they put an a.
All you do is take the r out and instead
of normally it wasn't a good boston
accent,
my really picking them apart.
Years after the door.
Norm.
Did you hear?
He went on opie and anthony show and
apparently they fucking kicked them off,
like really?
She's got some beer book he's putting
out now.
George went right,
right?
No,
no,
no.
The other.
George.
Yeah.
George wendt was mailman and the mailman
was clearly above the beer guy out.
If someone's going to put out a book,
it would have been normed.
It would have been.
George went,
yeah.
Well,
george wendt was on the opiod.
Anthony show and I don't know what
happened,
but just very unenthusiastic and they
want to kicking them out because he was
unenthusiastic.
Oh,
what happened?
I'm as informed as you are about the
economy.
Those fucking guys like that.
I always get excited.
Oh,
they had so and so on.
How did it go on?
Rats.
Fucking jimmy went in the other room,
started prank calling them,
and I had a job with jesse ventura.
That's my faith.
That's why he fucking destroyed them.
Each crushed them.
Thank you for your service to our
country and he was saluting them.
Dude.
I thought for once I was actually going
to see jesse and a real fight for all
those years of watching them take
flight.
I was in Vietnam.
Where were you?
Yeah,
it's got to be one of those weird
fucking stupid bullying things with
norton.
Hates it when when someone tries to
bully him,
you know,
when someone just demands respect
without fucking proven your point.
[inaudible] point and the.
It's crazy.
Just chewed him up.
I thought it was awesome.
Oh,
it was hilarious.
It was.
It was the combiNation of awesome.
And then also he was beating him so bad.
I felt bad for jessie.
I was like,
jesse,
tap out.
Well,
jesse's got the.
Yeah,
he did.
He left.
It was so stupid.
He's got this weird.
Jimmy was going to see it.
See a fucking leave.
So you're going to fucking leave.
And he's leaving.
God.
Jesse looked ugly at the end.
The look.
He was thinking about doing something
like throwing something at them or
yelling at them or just so hoping that
kenny was right there and I always
wanted to see kenny and actually,
you know,
he would just go old school,
dirty cop probably.
Well,
you know,
jeSsie's got bad hips.
Jesse's,
uh,
another one of those wrestlers that had
hip replacement surgery.
a lot of them have their hips replaced.
Do you know how [inaudible] like three
inches shorter from all those years of
jumping up all operations?
Because when I saw him,
I was like,
this guy's not that tall,
but he's fucking arms.
Get down below his knees.
I got like a fucking gorilla and then,
and then I've written,
this is,
well,
I don't want to fuck.
I saw it said he used to be six foot
seven and now he's six foot four.
There's a huge difference.
Six floors,
like,
you know,
we used to play college ball.
Six seven is off of his spine.
I wonder how many he's got fused.
A lot of guys get their shit fused.
Man,
that's a big thing in mma right now.
Tito ortiz just had his neck vertebrae
fused and uh,
there's a bunch of guys who had their
back fused,
kenny kenny fight anymore after that.
I don't know.
I mean,
it really depends on how he recovers,
you know,
but it's some serious,
serious shit.
You sure.
It wasn't just hairspray and heels that,
you know,
or something like that with hall cogans
serious back surgery more than one who's
the guy that hangs out at the comedy
store all the time.
Or he was for awhile that roddy roddy,
piper piper.
He's doing standup.
It's so weird if someones going on the
road with them.
Yeah.
You know,
steve,
someones,
uh,
you know,
steve mom,
see if someone's a comic out of the
comedy store has a huge fucking
wrestling fans.
Really good guy.
And he goes on the road with a rowdy
roddy piper and it does a little standup
and rowdy roddy tells the stories.
Apparently it's a hit.
Oh yeah,
dude,
I,
this,
this will really let you listen.
There's no way.
I don't know shit about banking.
I actually ordered it on amazon.
The hard copy version of a ric flair is
autobiography to beat the man.
You got to be the man to be the man.
You got to beat the man.
Dude.
It's one of those.
It's Just a fucking awesome book to ric
flair.
Have you ever watched his Clips?
Yeah.
Yeah,
I've seen one of the funniest fucking
dude.
He's just like a comedian where they
say,
do you have writers?
You know,
people write this and he goes to writer.
So he gets to do what I used to come up
with hat.
That shit on the cab ride over from the
air force.
Like a comedian.
He's just sitting there.
Exactly.
It just gets luby's something.
He just says,
fuck this dude.
He's got a couple of way.
He's so into it like you think he's
going to pass out and he's,
when he's yelling at people in the veins
of the way,
his eyes bulge out.
he's got one week.
Keeps going.
I inherited his voice,
keeps cracking.
He's screaming.
So I hadn't heard it about that,
that uh,
born with a golden spoon in his mouth.
Do it.
I'll be on the road depressed like,
oh my god,
I hate this and I'll just start watching
rick flair videos.
I just start laughing my fucking ass off
on that.
This is what it's about.
This is why you do it.
That guy is.
He's the shit.
Ric flair is fucking awesome.
My favorite wrestling videos that john
stossel video with john stossel is
talking to.
I don't remember what the wrestler was
telling them about.
You know that what you do is fake and a
fucking slaps him in the head like full
blast.
Slaps him in his ear and drop some of
those because that fake because I feel
fake.
You're telling me what's fake and it
gets up.
Bam.
He slaps him in the other year and drops
them again.
Then it gets up and runs out of there.
What was the one that was like?
Was it mr t or something like that where
he goes crazy.
It was like a live show and he starts
smacking or getting angry and I'm
freaking out.
Wrestler was that.
It was think mr.
T was on talking about hulk hogan
hawkish and belzer.
Richard belzer asleep.
Yeah,
that's what rIchard belzer fell and
bumped his head.
I got to see that video.
Oh,
I'm sure.
I'm sure it's online in this day and
age.
It would be convenient.
What you'd do is,
yeah,
you gotta be nice.
Those guys,
you can't disrespect them.
Plus they're on gallons of juice,
you know?
Oh,
they get the sicknesses.
They get that big.
You know that crispin wog on that one of
killing his whole family juice to the
gills.
Yeah.
But that's also another thing too,
is me,
unlike pain meds,
because those guys did like doesn't work
in like seven nights a fucking week.
It's the thing about a bass who fight in
the ufc.
Like brock says that pro wrestling is
way harder than being the ufc
heavyweight champion.
How about that?
Is that the video?
I'm sorry,
I'm going to watch a young.
Back in the day,
they just google it.
You could fit in.
Work this out.
Did they know this isn't like a bit.
I don't think so.
Oh yeah,
and hulk hogan.
Oh,
you got them in a keith,
you put them asleep.
Oh,
you went out looking at it
right?
That's pretty fucked up.
I mean,
he really was out.
That's no bullshit.
He just let them fall to the ground.
I put a to sleep on a radio show once.
No,
no,
no.
He was just fucking around with.
No,
no,
he wasn't.
You see the way fell,
dude.
He fell in and slammed his head off the
ground.
He was trying to.
Yeah,
he's trying to cover for it.
Anyway,
that's a,
that's a famous one
in the,
in the lead up to that.
It was like a hulk.
Hogan was getting really pissed off at
him.
Like,
like the whole time,
like there was like seven minutes up to
that or six minutes up to he being a
smart ass and just pissing the hulk off
like in for real.
why would you do that?
Even if even if what they did was really
fake,
you know?
I mean obviously you know that
predetermined the victor of stuff and
when somebody fucking slams you down to
back,
it hurts.
YeaH.
You gotta be conscious of who you're
talking to.
Those guys are savages.
You know,
even though even though they're not,
they might not be actually fighting for
a living.
They will fuck you.
They beat the shit out of you if they
want to like,
you better be nice.
They live in a wild world to a lot wild
world of sweaty men that you hoist
through the air and slammed on their
back.
You know,
their idea of like what's acceptable
danger and punishment that you take with
your body is not what most people's is.
You know,
for them it's like,
oh,
he just fell asleep.
Belzer was covering.
That was pretty good.
No,
he wasn't covering.
He went,
going to say he was a.
I think he was the lead up was trust me.
The guy went out.
That's 100 percent unconscious.
That's what we're saying.
We're saying it was covering up that.
oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Belzer was covering as a pro at the end.
Yeah.
Yeah,
definitely.
Yeah.
Well he went to sleep,
no doubt about it.
The way guy that guy squeezed is 100
percent the way his arms go limp.
How long does it take?
Two seconds.
When a guy puts a gun to choke,
there was a guy I choked out on a radio
show.
There was this radio show,
uh,
he was like a,
um,
you know,
a pa and they had them do little stunts
and stuff and if he couldn't do it then
they would punish them.
You know,
There's like this gag.
They used to do it.
It was in boston.
So they had this dude dress up as a cow
and he had a fucking try to jump over a
chair on rollerblades and he couldn't
make it over.
The cherrY falls and crashes and they
get them upstairs and I go,
okay,
now now you know,
your punishment is going to be joe rogan
has to choke me unconscious.
I go,
wHat?
And he goes,
okay,
I'll do it.
I'll go to you,
really,
you sure about this?
and he goes,
yeah,
I go,
you sure?
And he goes,
yeah.
I go,
all right.
So I go,
if you just,
when you can't take it,
just tap out.
And I locked the choke on them,
squeeze on,
and he goes to tap and he's already
unconscious and I let them go thinking
that he tapped and he falls and fucking
face plants on the carpet boxes.
Head of the carpet.
It was only,
he only fell a couple of inches,
but he was unconscious immediately.
If you just let someone squeeze your
neck,
he'd go out pretty quick.
Do you know that became the thing to do
for like,
like maybe like a week and a half.
When I was in seventh grade,
we didn't understand what we were doing
with somebody came up with it choking
now we you do is you would just
basically grabbed two handfuls of
somebody's neck on each side grabbing
that juggler.
But the thIng about it was,
was like this.
Yeah.
We Didn't know what we were doing.
We didn't know what we're doing.
So some people were just grabbing like,
you know what,
neck muscle they will,
they will back here.
But occasionally people would grab them.
Right.
False shit.
Yeah.
The file.
What happened with someone did it
correctly and the dude did the same
thing.
He fell straight forward and uh,
and then there was announcements,
announcements at the end of the day and
there's been a fad around the school to
be grabbing your classmates next.
His whole fucking thing.
It's very dangerous.
You're depriving oxygen to the temporal
lobe and all this fucking bullshit.
And it just basically.
Could you please stop choking?
I wonder how many kids today approximate
mma moves on their friends at school?
You know,
you watch the ultimate fighter or
something like that.
She wouldn't get him.
He gotta make memorial let me show you.
Yeah.
The first time I ever thrown my back was
in fourth grade.
I let this kid put me in the figure four
leg lock.
I swear to god because that was because
I was also an unbelievable.
It's not real.
It doesn't hurt.
And it was killing me.
So I was,
I was,
I was leaning up to try to take his leg
off.
It's the first time I felt lower back
pain.
Fourth grade,
you're jacked.
You're back in the fourth grade.
It's fucking with you ever since.
Figure four leg lock.
Well,
uh,
it didn't fuck with me until football a
few years later,
unorganized,
of course,
because I never had the grades.
But uh,
that's,
that's when it really got bad.
But the first first back pain ever had.
What do you thinking about those people
that say that back pain is all
psychological?
No,
that's bull shit.
Are you serious?
There's people that actually say that
john sarno guy on it.
There's fucking,
there are a lot of people that have
psychological back pain.
Absolutely.
The injuries it exists but doesn't mean
it.
It's all this
guy like he,
he,
I don't know if he says all of them,
but I think he attributes a lot of them.
He's talking about people,
even if they have injuries,
the injuries don't really hurt nearly as
much as I think they
do.
It's all psychosomatic.
I agree that he's basically saying we're
a bunch of pussies pussies.
Yeah.
Bunch of pussies.
And the idea is that the injuries a
distract you from other stress,
you know,
and take it.
Well,
I'm a firm believer of just stretching
yoga and that type of shit because,
uh,
I don't know what happens when you get
older,
but even just sleeping the amount more
that your,
your attendance or whatever shrivel up
like that.
If you have a sodomy hobbled to the
bathroom in the morning,
you would think that I played like five
years of professional ball or I don't
know what's going on with me.
So I put if I stretched before I go to
bed or something like that,
I'm way better really.
My forte,
my foot is fucking jacked.
It's an old injury I had from playing
drums and uh,
it's a real hard to drum injury.
Yeah,
you'd be surprised.
Some other drummers went up,
planters,
fish a lot on what the fuck they call
it,
but it was from I was,
I had poor technique and I was trying to
do this bass drum lick a,
this thing that john bonham did and the
song good times,
bad times.
These really quick,
a 16th note,
triplets,
triplets.
I'm sure you heard that.
The fight game.
And uh,
I was trying,
I had bad technique.
What I was doing and I,
I fucked up the arch of it and it
literally felt like as I was walking
down the street,
someone was like,
I was stepping on nails and I didn't
know what to do.
Typical irish guy,
I just thought,
well just fucking stick it in the air
for a minute and it'll be fine.
And I tuft and I finally had to go.
This is literally,
you got to like take a bottled water,
freeze it in the fridge,
right and step on it.
And then just sit there rolling on the
bottom.
You foot antiinflammatories.
Then you've gotta.
Then you got arrested up.
So what is the actual injuries
attendant?
I don't fucking know.
Carpal tunnel for drummers.
I always stop and tHink about if I lived
like just 100 years ago or even less,
I would be useless.
My body's been screwed back together so
many different times.
Somebody different things.
I've had three pretty significant knee
surgeries to reconstructions both knees
over the acl.
Replaced this one.
I had my meniscus done,
I had my nose fixed,
my nose was broken.
Who knows how many fucking times.
So they had a scoop out all the shit out
of my nose and a deviated septum repair.
I stop and think about it like if,
if modern science wasn't around modern
medicine,
I'd be fuck you be an ogre.
I'll be living under a bridge a bit
crippled.
I wouldn't be able to do anything for
without fear of my legs given out and
popping out and fall onto the ground and
in agony.
That's just what people did back then.
Well,
I would've been dead.
My appendix ruptured in the sixth grade.
That would've been.
It would've been a wrap.
Wow.
One of those cakes ruptures.
What happens?
Your parents tell you to go take a nap
and they don't believe it.
And then finally they'd take it down
there and you,
uh,
you almost die.
Wow.
I always present yourselves for that
one.
They just didn't believe,
you know,
I don't know.
My brothers convinced I was playing
baseball and that's what happened.
I don't even remember.
I just kept having like side pain and
then then the next day I would feel
fine.
Then I have a fever and then I would
feel fine.
And then one day,
I guess it just burst.
Isn't it crazy that what
your appendix is an organ that you don't
use anymore because it's used to meet.
Yeah.
So evolve past bone,
breaking doWn bone is your is your urine
or in Oregon?
I thought your organs like the liver,
pancreas,
google,
intestines.
Find out what the fuck it is.
I'm pretty sure that would intestine is
not a test in the appendix rather would
appendix is is an organ that we used to
use when we processed meat,
we processed much more raw meat.
You know,
I thought it was when we ate leaves,
that was bone phrase.
Jesus,
look at it between the three of us,
we don't have a fucking clue if it's
something that we're evolving.
We're evolving so we don't use it
anymore.
WHich is pretty fascinating when you
think about it.
It's actually mean.
It couldn't have been that long ago.
It's like clear evidence that the human
body is adapting to its environment and
then we literally don't use this fucking
Oregon anymore.
And sometimes it blows up in your body,
you know?
I mean that's what it does right?
It just fucking suicide bombs.
I would've been,
I would've died too,
that there's a couple of things I would
have died if I broke my arm when I was
six.
I got hit by a car.
If I,
if it was the 18 hundreds,
I would have died,
but I get hit by it,
like getting hit by that car.
18 hundreds was hit by a car.
I didn't look.
I was racing my brother home and he had
stronger legs than I did.
So,
uh,
I figured if I cross,
I was sure I looked and I just do right
out in front of a jeep.
I wish I had video because I stIll don't
know how I didn't get run over.
All I remember was being upside down and
feeling the heat of the engine and
seeing the bumper.
Oh my.
And then the next thing I remember,
I was lying perpendicular to the,
uh,
the double lines.
I was only out for a second,
just like belzer when he got choked out.
it was only off for a second because
when I came to,
uh,
the biggest dude,
sonia life gets out of this jeep,
he probably had nightmares because of
the way I just wrote out in front of me
already crying.
Oh.
and I all I could think was my dad's
going to fucking kill me.
and I got up and I ran a only thing that
fucking happened.
Well,
anything that other than I got knocked
out was,
uh,
you know,
that thing here,
if you bite down on your back teeth,
that thing that goes in and out on the
side of your head.
THat's right where I got hurt.
So I had to eat with a little spoon for
a couple of days.
I remember it happened on a wednesday
because the doctor says you don't have
to go to school for the rest of the
week.
And I was psyched.
I finally didn't have to fake school and
I had fucking thursday,
friday,
saturday,
and sunday off.
It was totally worth it.
I think
it was one of the reasons why I stopped
fighting is because when I was
kickboxing,
oh,
there was many nights where couldn't
chew my food.
I'd come home and I literally couldn't
chew all because too much side of the
head and I would get headaches.
I'd lay in bed at night and get fUcking
viciouS headaches.
That was not fun.
Scary shit.
Food opportune food gunner,
you know,
you get kicked in the fucking jaw.
That's not fun.
You know,
he kicked or punched in the head,
like really blasted your jaw just gets
funded.
I fought
right up right up until fifth grade and
then all the.
I went from being one of the bigger kids
to one of the smaller kids and then also
kids started getting to be like a buck
20 and kind of knowing how to throw a
punch and it like I saw,
I saw scary dude.
I totally became a coward.
I became funny all of a sudden,
bunch of dudes who had brain damage.
I knew a bunch of dudes from boxing gyms
that had brain damage wasn't too
significant,
but it was enough that you could see it.
And I had seen guys from uh,
you know,
when I started when I was 15 and I'd
seen how he evolved into how they
develop brain damage up until,
you know,
when I was 21,
when I stopped finding 21 or 22,
I got to see the deterioration.
That's some scary shit.
What's his face?
He knows,
saved me.
I went,
I went to go get,
I wanted to get in shape when I was
living in New York.
So our started going to gleason's gym,
but I just did it like total,
like actor.
I just want to get shredded.
They will call me like billary swank and
shit.
I say about this yet given me shit.
So charlie murphy fucking gave me great
advice because I told him I was starting
to go over there because he's only good
at martial arts shit.
And he goes and he just called me and
said,
hey,
your bill,
let me tell you something.
And he totally fucking broke it down.
He's like,
you're going to be over there for like
eat literally broke that because you're
going to be over there for like fucking
maybe a month,
month and a half,
and somebody's gonna come up to you and
tell you that you look like you're
decent and they're basically gonna try
to talk you into getting into the ring
because they need fresh meat and he
goes,
do not go in there under any
circumstance.
I'm like,
whatever.
Charlie always preaching this
apocalyptic shit.
They would literally clockwork six weeks
over there,
fucking black dude shredded comes up to
me.
Hey,
you're a comedian man.
You know,
looked like a comedian.
Like how you've got a nice jab or
whatever,
you know,
we want to spar a few rounds.
I almost started laughing.
It was so exactly what the fuck he said.
I was like,
get the fuck some six weeks,
six weeks in a comedian.
this fucking guy has been fighting for
like 10 years as a beat you up.
He wanTed to try this shit that he
didn't have the balls to try against a
professional.
he was going to try some new,
I don't know,
superman hook.
Is that a punch?
I don't know what the fuck it was.
He wanted to try it on my moods.
Do look for guys a spar with it.
Looked to beat guys up
to improve their confidence and you
know,
try the techniques on.
Nobody wants to spar with the guy that's
going to beat the fuck out of here.
You want to spar with a guy who's going
to just kind of barely put up a fight
and you gonna be able to tee off on them
and it's like
glorified.
That's basically what charlie told me.
It's true.
And probably murphy gave you some good
advice.
Great advice.
I tell him he laughed his ass off when I
told him that because he just started.
He just started thinking about my big
stupid charlie had getting battered
around the ring.
Boxing gyms are notorious for that shit.
See when that happens in jujitsu,
it's really no big deal.
I remember when I first started doing
jujitsu,
I started rolling with guys who are
really good and like just getting
humiliated,
getting strangled.
There was this one purple belt kid.
I was a white belt.
I was.
I was on news radio and I was just
starting out and this is purple belt kid
is brazilian kid who was bad ass and he
used to fucking raped me.
Everyday I would.
I would be terrified to have to fucking
roll with this kid because he was really
good.
I was,
and every
time I'd run with them,
this motherfucker would mount me and
choked me and armbar me.
He would tap me three,
four times and I was exhausted just over
and over and over again.
He would tap me now,
but it didn't hurt me.
You know what I'm saying?
What was the level of frustration coming
from being a national champion and
ongoing
was it was eyeopening?
Well,
there was one of the reasons why I
stopped doing taekwondo is because
taekwondo,
you don't punch to the head and the
tournament's and I started kickboxing.
I started working with.
There was a guy named joe lake was a
boxing coach in boston and he was
training at the same gym that I was at
and he was offering me to teach me
boxing if I would teach him how to kick,
and so we sort of made this little deal
and we'll work back and forth with each
other and I started boxing and as I
started boxing I realized how bad my
hands were from taekwondo and then I'm
like,
I've wasted all my time doing this
taekwondo shit,
but then when I go box with guys and
kickbox,
I'm fucking terrible with my hands.
So I started getting really good at my
hands and working on it.
So I'd already been enligHtened to the
fact that my original path was not the
best path in the world and one of the
reasons why I stopped fighting.
I stopped fighting and taekwondo
tournament because I realized how silly
it was,
how easy it was for people to punch me
in the face and how many techniques
didn't work.
Once you added punching.
Then when the ultimate fighting
championship came along,
I realized like,
oh,
well look what this fucking guy does.
He just,
you know,
hoists gracie just takes guys down and
strangles them.
What the fuck would I do if that guy got
me,
I don't know,
shit.
So I started doing jujitsu and I was
just a rank beginner.
I was,
I wrestled one year in high school,
so I knew how to throw bodies around a
little bit,
but I didn't know how to defend myself
against anybody who's any good and this
kid just mangled me over and,
but he never really hurt me,
you know,
if this was kickboxing and he did that
to me,
he would've given me brain damage,
but my face knocked me out.
But this guy just choked me and I just
tapped and yarn,
pardon me?
And I tapped.
But he's not really hurting you.
Every time he's doing this to you,
just tap,
just emotionally devastating.
You don't realize until you roll with a
guy who's good,
how a guy who's like that a,
you know,
high level purple builds,
a strong guy can just do whatever the
fuck he wants to you.
Like literally,
you have no defense.
There's almost nothing you can do if you
don't punch him and knock him
unconscious as he's grabbing a hold of
you.
Once it grabs You,
you're a victim.
You're a victim.
You know,
it's almost like if you get grabbed by
like a bear,
like a wild animal,
it's a second.
They grab your button down,
your worse for the bear finished.
You imagine what it must feel like.
There's a photo that a guy took.
He,
uh,
he died.
He was killed by this bear,
but he got one last photograph of the
female charging him because he was a
wildlife photographer.
It's a very famous photo aNd he was in
the woods and as he's walking through
the woods,
he stumbled upon bear cubs as you
stumble upon It was just too late.
The female just runs out.
I'm a grizzly and he got a photo of her
fucking lips curled teeth bared,
roaring and looking at him with dead
eyes and that was his last photo that I
ever took.
It's a fucking intense photo of you find
it online.
Anybody finds online twitter?
That shit to me because I lost it.
I had it online.
I was showing it to somebody and then I
cannot find it anymore.
I don't know if it was pulled or what.
Jesus,
you know when I was in Colorado,
my dog got eaten by mountain lion.
Oh yeah.
I've been keeping up on you just
see.
Just so you know,
we're at the two hour and 20 mInutes.
I know where we are.
We should probably on this because
nobody wants it.
Let's do a two hour and 20 minute
podcast about podcasts.
We should talk to you monday.
He does not have fucking twitter,
so we got him a god damn twitter
account.
Bill.
You got that shit.
It helps you.
It's the best thing for a comic to use
right now.
It shows.
I would not.
I would have known that you had a
podcast.
if I,
if I heard something on twitter,
you know that that's by design my
pockets.
We don't hype it.
I don't know.
Hype,
my podcast.
I totally,
I do it for fun and it's,
it's,
I go,
I'm waiting,
right?
Yeah.
But people don't know.
But you got,
you fucking know me.
You know me.
You didn't even know I had one.
I know you had one.
I didn't know you had one.
I think that you knew that I had one but
you didn't.
I remember you should do it with a
phone.
The phone.
I do,
yeah,
but I just don't.
I don't give a fuck.
How do you do it now?
You sit down with a microphone now and
just ran the same thing.
Yeah.
People send me questions and then I,
I just go off on shit.
So now you don't do it on a phone,
you don't do that anymore?
No,
I haven't done it on a phone now for
about a voice mail thing.
Year and a half.
Oh yeah.
When I used to call up ge cath.
But that was,
that was a lot of fun though because I
could be an airport's making fun of
fucking the creeps at cinnabon and all
that and people really liked that.
So I don't hAve a fucking twitter
account.
I dude,
I just got on facebook,
but facebook's good.
But twitter is great for promoting gigs.
Like I got a gig.
The punchline is duncan.
Okay,
sounds rolling.
I got a kick it,
the punchline in atlanta this sunday.
I just booked it because I knoW I'm
going to be in atlanta on monday and I
had to fly In sunday afternoon.
So I said,
well I'll just do a fucking show there.
So I,
I just started promoting it.
I started promoting it on fucking
twitter.
I just threw it up on twitter.
I'm in to let people know.
So then people started retweet,
knit and letting people know it's almost
fucking sold out.
That's all you have to do,
joe rogan television.
But people know who you are.
It helps build you're a celebrity.
When I told people that you were coming
on the podcast,
people got all fucking excited and fired
up on twitter.
A bunch of them on twitter,
I'll show you know,
something filling seats.
They'll burn against this fuzzy math
look.
I'll show you.
There's a lot of people in here that
we're talking about bill burr.
There's a lot of people look at
scrolling,
scrolling five bill burr on twitter
right there.
Bam.
Is bill burr on twitter?
People trying and that's what you do.
You leave them wanting more.
Joe,
you know how much fucking it's a pain in
the ass to do all that.
It's so easy.
If you have an iphone,
what?
You have a blackberry.
I fucking twitter every week on my
podcast.
I for an hour and you could listen to
what twitter.
It's on to the same thing.
Twitter is like a text message that you
send to all your fans.
So like I've got 130 something thousand
people on my quit showing off.
We already know one slash 31 slash 75.
So that is 131,000
people that I can get in contact with
pretty much instantly.
I mean if they pay attention to their
twitter,
you know,
all you have to do is your twitter,
hey,
I'm going to be in fucking newport
beach,
bam.
And then you can get people to come to
your shows.
It's so much easier.
It's so much easier than going on a
radio show and getting up in the
morning.
You could fucking get things.
I'm always like,
I always liked the old school way of
doing shit.
I always think it's better.
I don't know why I'm an old school sort
of a guy.
I'm a romantic.
You are romantic.
And by the way,
joe,
that bear photo is fake.
I'll get on twitter is fake.
Yeah.
Which one is the one with the dead body?
I dunno.
You talking about?
Oh no,
no,
that's,
that's a different one.
Yeah,
I will.
The other one is start tweeting black
and white.
That's what it was.
That tweeting.
That just sounded clay tweeting.
Tweet.
Say it joe.
Just say.
Yeah.
I tweeted about that yesterday.
Yeah,
you looked away.
Where are you going to be out this
weekend?
Where can people see you?
I'm going to be at the,
uh,
the improv on melrose hollywood improv
and next weekend I'm going to be at the
orleans with tom papa.
Co Headline with tom papa.
The last last gig a george carlin ever
did was at the orleans casino in vegas.
It's a great place.
I'm going to be there.
I've been there for fights.
Um,
billboard.com,
bur [inaudible] dot com.
And I have a and a.
What the fuck is,
I don't know what it is.
I have a podcast.
If you click on the podcast link
[inaudible] dot com slash podcast and
you can find it on itunes.
It's called jonah monday morning
podcast.
we got him a fucking twitter account.
Okay.
We're going to force him into,
again,
twitter.
We're going to set it up here.